priem grand prix entre alexandra
kosteniuk un petit koné roues donc on va
commencer par le match pour la troisième
place avec un intérêt incroyable les
amis vraiment un enjeu un enjeu de poids
puisque on va savoir qui termine
finalement 3e du quatrième grand prix
féminin de l'année
donc j'ai envie de dire
match au sommet entre entre les deux
entre les deux femmes
et on va suivre ça ensemble et on va on
va passer une heure une heure
quarante-cinq palpitant que la sueur sur
ce premier match qui va qui va nous
amener vers vers la finale pour savoir
si kosteniuk ira en grande finale qui
aura lieu lundi puisque le tournoi se
terminera se terminera demain donc du
coup lundi donc pour cette grande finale
après un peu plus de 4 à plein plus d'un
mois si on compte les qualifications à
mois et demi de compétition pour pour se
finir sur ce lundi 20 juillet
donc on aura là la finale je vérifier
que le live soit bien parti
voilà ouais là on est on est bon je vais
ouvrir le chat on va on va être bon
aussi avec avec le chat est ce qu'on a
des utilisateurs oui n'hésitez pas à
mettre un petit message justement dans
ce même chat
histoire de savoir alors que je suis sur
la réunion mais que personne ne m'amène
vers les caméras
donc on est un peu dans le caca par
rapport à ça mais ça va bientôt arriver
alors du coup ça me pose juste un petit
souci au niveau du démarrage du match
parce que j'ai peut-être plus de mal à
voir les joueuses
alors j'ai pas leur ce dos du coup alors
attendez sahara je vais avoir son pseudo
voilà on va suivre ça donc qui va jouer
ce premier match contre ou leaf and
numéro un mondial donc je vous rappelle
l'enjeu 2
de ce match savoir qui terminera 3e du
quatrième grand prix fidh
c'est l'enjeu l'enjeu de ce match
en ce début de dimanche après midi
on va voir on va voir ce que ça donne
espérons que les jeux les jouets soient
motivés après elles ne peuvent plus se
qualifier 1 ni l'une ni l'autre ne
peuvent se qualifier pour la grande
finale elles sont toutes les deux
éliminés déjà mais elles peuvent finir
troisièmes avec une médaille de bronze
quand même très très honorifique pour
laquelle les deux joueuses vont se
battre à fond et tout donner pour
ajouter une ligne à leur palmarès
palmarès qui pourrait qui pourrait
s'étoffer donc pour les deux joueuses
parce que pour une raison x ou y j'ai
pas les caméras que je vois que les
partis sont à voir les parties viennent
de partir voilà ça y est on allait
partir je sais pas pourquoi on m'a pas
mis sur les calmes
je sais pas bon on va jouer je vais
essayer de les récupérer à la pause je
vais attendre et je vais écrire un petit
message les amis
désolé une petite seconde
je verrai un message a pris vos mecs qui
peut faire ça
je vais écrire ça une seconde donc c'est
une espagnole en de toute façon vous
connaissez petite vente avec fu 17 ces
trois des quatre voilà juste le message
est envoyé le tan tient et donc
et donc quoi le fou qui vient angers7
stanis différé à exactement ce qu'a fait
des 5
cet échange des fous ce plutôt une bonne
opération pour les blancs d'échangé
c'est fou de casement je vous voyez vous
avez les pions ici sur cases blanches le
pion qui vient au f5 lecavalier qui va
venir en aide si s'en prendre aux eaux
pures carré ttf 4g 5 h 5 g 4 cavaliers
j'ai six cavaliers h4 ça peut être un
genre un genre d'idées alors que ça y
est je vais être joué à être invités aux
caméras et qu'on va pouvoir avoir les
caméras d
deux joueuses alors on va faire le petit
réglage du coup en direct avec sarah qui
va très vite être cadré vous voyez pas
la petite manip que je fais mais je fais
une petite manip les gars qui va pas
durer très longtemps
allez hop là transit est parti du conte
à l'ecam alors désolé pour willy fans si
on voit pas plus que son que ses cheveux
c'est tout simplement parce que elle
même c'est mal cadré à la caméra donc je
peux pas y faire grand chose donc willy
fan numéro un mondial qui a eu un peu de
mal dans ces compétitions notamment elle
a eu des petits problèmes de connexion
certaines fois et d'autres fois
peut-être que son niveau de jeu n'est
pas n'est pas toujours au rendez vous je
vous rappelle qu'elle est qu elle a
terminé ses études que c'est donc une
joueuse plutôt amateur 1 oui fans même
si elle est numéro un mondial
elle est professeur d'université je
crois à shenzhen si je dis pas de
bêtises et dont l'université dans
laquelle elle enseigne
c'est la plus jeune professeur de
l'histoire de l'université donc elle a
des choses importantes à faire entre
guillemets et quentin la tour il est
française joue pas non elles n'ont pas
réussi à se qualifier
les joueuses françaises n'ont pas alors
marie se bat agh aurait peut-être pu
participer mais là je sais pas si elle a
refusé aussi à la rate et la qualif et
les autres joueuses étaient peut-être un
petit peu en dessous de du top niveau du
top niveau chez les femmes
en tout cas elles n'ont pas réussi à se
qualifier il marie ce bague n'a pas non
pas si elles étaient contactées ou quad
mais en tout cas la voilà participa donc
on à sarah en bas donc comme d'habitude
à la caméra on regarde de côté sa rage
pas si mathieu va passer par par le live
ou pas écoutez cette partie on va on
voit relation va suivre ce match donc je
vous rappelle que la finale aura lieu
aux alentours de 16h15 de ce quatrième
grand prix et ça nous amènera
après attendait pourquoi j'ai un double
non là c'est terrible et ça nous amènera
après donc demain vers la grande finale
des grands prix dont cadref de pro côté
est côté sarah où les prix sont rachetés
ans pas que les prix soient faits mais
il ya quand même 50 de 1000 $ de prix
sur toute la compétition
il y aura je crois rien que pour les
deux joueuses en finale dix mille
dollars de prix je crois que ses 6500
pour la gagnants de demain du gros truc
et 3500 juste pour la finaliste et il ya
des prix aussi sur tous les tournois je
crois que c'est 3000 pour la gagnante de
chaque grand prix donc niveau de priest
est quand même assez bien assez bien
dotées quand même pour un 3 sur internet
bon après c'est sur quatre semaines les
50000 dollars de prix c'est quand même
pas rien pour nous ça peut paraître un
peu long mais les joueuses jouent leur
match sur match dure 1h30 tous les
matches se jouent pas en même temps et
qu'ils ont plus tard un format très long
à regarder sûrement pour pour qui un
maximum de spectateurs via le temps mais
nokia via le via via le concise mans de
la compétition met donc il ya pas tant
d'heures de jeu que ça un match dure
1h30 pour gagner un tournoi il faut
gagner quatre matchs donc c'est si tu
gagnes pour six heures de jeu
tu peux gagner à trois mille 3000 $ plus
si tu gagnes par exemple deux grands
prix pour ça qu'ils gagnent plusieurs
grands prix en 18 20 heures de jeu elles
peuvent elles peuvent empocher plus de
plus de 15000 dollars je pense si elles
réussissent à fond donc c'est plutôt
c'est plutôt pas mal surtout que même
même en perdant on s'assure tout de même
un prix donc c'est une structure de
pions qui est un petit peu est indienne
avec les blancs qui attaque allait droit
à l'ale dame parlant les noirs allaient
le roi du rapt f 4g 5 h 4 pour pousser à
fond on va voir ce que ça donne
dame de jouer sans prend un petit peu au
pion des 5
bon alors comment il continue je vérifie
juste un petit truc avec avec twitch
j'oublie mais de mettre le petit hosting
j'ai oublié de mettre le hosting je vais
le mettre maintenant ça peut quand même
être utile
ça va être fait allez bim
ben voilà c'est réussi donc pour ces
huit elle vient un petit peu contesté la
colonne c'est avec les noirs on va voir
si les blancs réussissent à organiser
quelque chose
le long de cette colonne c'est justement
aussi les noirs sont à temps pour
bloquer et peut-être plus tard attaqué à
l'oeil droit
peut-être h cinq fois je sis aussi peut
être un plan pour échanger se fout de
cases noires je pense que les noirs ont
un avantage ici il ya aussi cavalier h5
carré des f4 qui peut être un plan mais
c'est une position extrêmement complexe
je sais pas si j'ai raison quand j clés
noires sont un peu mieux mais blanc
attaque aussi quand même rapidement
c'est loin d'être aussi simple que ça
c'est vrai que c'est dans ces écrits
prem's à everly sandales ski et qui est
loin d'être prem's d'ailleurs hier soir
il y avait pas grand monde sur les live
ça pas été n'étaient pas très nombreux
hier j'ai l'impression qu'il ya pas mal
de gens là ce week end qui sont soit
partis en vacances soit qui ont décidé
d'aller se se faire des barbecues je ne
sais quoi et vous avez bien raison de
profiter de votre été on est toujours là
kml stade qui était là oui bécane des
gens est un peu plus de 500 mais souvent
les plus de 600 700 way samedi soir les
gens qui retournent au boulot
mais même en général même sur les trucs
anglais même sur youtube y avait pas
énormément de vue pas énormément de
monde de partout mais ça ça se comprend
les amis même la rediff de la master
class de fabre n'y a pas grand monde qui
regarde et j'entends qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui sont partis en vacances ce
week-end je sais pas si c'est votre
votre cas dans le tchat
en tout cas ça échange
casas échanges marty prennent à eux
quatre
j'en prends le 4 elle va sûrement
reprendre du pillon j'imagine ça aussi
cavalier des princes 4 qui est possible
avec qui est aussi très possible et ça
lui a mis le doigt me dit que ce qu'ils
aiment voir une intérieure c'était une
espagnole qui a tourné en est indienne
kaki angers 4 maintenant mais mon risque
qui est prend 1,3 est vraiment un
problème dur à dire mais le fou b6
retour en f1 alors à tourcoing f1 a fait
tourbe et 8 ouais c'est compliqué comme
position difficile de juger un camp
c'est du jeu déséquilibré comme ça alors
est-ce que des tours prend b6 damaseb
fonctionner je crois que jacques et
prend 1,4 qui sauva way qui protège donc
ça c'est pas possible
peut-être un carré lisse ses 8 peut être
intéressant pour attaquer le fou essayer
de s'en prendre à b4 willy fans qui se
retrouve mal autant
x 5 damas est 3h un cavalier f2 tour
problème de dame prend f2 et cavaliers
prend à 4 donc les noirs qui ont gagné
une qualité à présent mes mails et blanc
qui ont toujours du jeu allèles d'années
qui ont pu y ont passé alors je préfère
largement les noirs mais ce n'est pas
dit que ce soit gagnant le fou g7
regardant un mur lequel ces quatre bien
placé les tours bloqué là-bas ambiguïté
à huit paquets ipv6 gpv puisque qu'elle
prend v6 qui a éprouvé six tours à 7
et ça a permis d'échanger ce qui avalise
c8 qui était mal placé jusqu'à
maintenant le cari qui revient la dame
qui va courir tentaculaire en recettes
ou tour 17 ans dams est joué h3 et
peut-être un x 6 x f4 là qui va rôder
autour des 1 elle conserve la tour d'amd
set elle empêche b5 et b6 dames 8 km et
4 le retour d'amd 8 k et des deux tours
f7 cavaliers f3 donc être bien colmaté
maintenant b5 va peut-être partir c'est
parti d'ailleurs fonction qui va
peut-être venir à foug b4 c'est bien
joué
cette décision est sans chaînes
damas tourbe et 8 x 5 auquel défend le
pion tête 1 dames c3 maintenant et bien
jouer d'amd depuis qu'une seconde pour
ou ifan qui va finir par tomber
c'est terrible on n'était pas très bien
après un mais c'est pas sûr qu'elle
qu'elle ait gagné ce jeu liste de cas
soir flores indienne non mais je te
recommande sur l'east indienne kings
indian oil faire de didier aspirine
ouais c'est la petite finale pour
commencer donc comme j'ai dit un match
donc voilà dans l'intérêt de savoir qui
terminera 3e de ce grand prix fina n'y a
pas d'autres là il ya plus aucun autre
intérêt
c'est comme un match important à suivre
1 pour savoir 1 une ligne sur le
palmarès
j'ai terminé troisième d'un grand prix
fidh féminin sur sur internet
donc c c'est l'enjeu c'est l'enjeu
aujourd'hui on verra bien qui réussit
cette performance
donc on a cette petite nîmes zoo et
salue jojo salua caillage salut
volovitch donc après aujourd'hui on aura
encore demain la grande finale des
speechs à 100 sur les deux premières sur
toute la compétition pour vraiment
savoir qui est la plus forte
dans cette compétition
donc ça sera
ça sera demain alors j'ai pas leurs jeux
regarder si j'ai l'heure mais je crois
que c'est 14h30 pareil
et on aura ensuite en août les
olympiades sur internet donc ça va durer
un mois et demi plus d'un mois et ça
commencera à ça le 29 juillet mais on
commentera peut-être pas forcément dès
le premier tour mais on commencera
peut-être un peu plus tard le principe
de la pièce c'est très compliqué encore
un vrai ça dure un mois et demi ouais un
peu plus d'un mois
peut-être peut-être si l'on aurait dû
peut-être un mois n'a pas toutes les
équipes qui jouent en même temps ça à
faire 40 min groupe c'est pas un peu
longtemps je pense que c'est un peu
court brettonier je pense qu'on aurait
dû faire ça sur quatre cinq mois comme
comme ces speech sc situation mine en
lattes as 2 semaines ça me paraît taillé
quatre semaines sans compter la phase de
qualification ça me paraît un peu court
peut-être plutôt fallu le faire sur cinq
six mois avoir plusieurs années histoire
de bien être sûr que le meilleur gagne
c'est pareil quand même important là ces
formats courts
donc ouais et l'équipe de france
l'équipe de france qui sera pour les
olympiades extrêmement faible puisque je
crois qu'il ya zéro grand maître qui
participe pour la france ouais sur cinq
ans histoire d'être bien sûr quoi mais
ça me paraît très bon format nature joue
toutes les semaines pendant cinq ans et
à la fin tu compte les points à quoi -
tu as eu le temps de bien progresser de
voir si les gens enfin voilà elle
suivait dans la durée que permet d'avoir
plus de qualité quoi newey donc l'équipe
française qui aura zéro grand maître je
crois j'ai vu la liste c'est à dire
c'est pas très fort j'ai pas vu un
joueur au dessus de 2500 lots ah bon
alors que les états unis par exemple
auront domine gaz et sow pour les hommes
que que les rues seront les grilles de
choc double car jaeckin et compagnie et
nous l'équipe de france je crois que
notre premier rishikesh tu seras morisi
donc on est quand même bien loin de du
niveau des deux meilleurs de dnv el baki
je me rappelle plus mais je peux vous
dire je peux trouver ça c'est quand même
intéressant ça permet de parler un petit
peu d'échecs là pendant ce match puisque
aiment l'équipe de france
en attendant je vais regarder si je
trouve ces olympiades en ligne
dans les amphis coeur faut que je trouve
attendez un
je vais vous trouvez ça j'ai pas j'avais
pas mis le voit la foule line optimizer
donc à des belges équipe genre la russie
longreach nepomniachi chez les hommes la
gnaque ariège qui n'a chez les femmes
meilleurs juniors ici piano puisqu'il ya
un junior dans l'équipe et meilleur
junior fille shuvalova poulina donc ça
c'est l'équipe tournait cet exemple et
chinois qui auront dingli rennes
louis-ii chez les hommes où il fane joue
auncun chez les femmes et liu yan que je
connais pas grand maître chez les
juniors et joue jean heures grand match
et juniors filles avec comme remplaçant
junghee bout thann
il y aura la petite mine cailloux enfin
y'a du monde les américains qui auront
donc sauf shankland je veux dire les
hommes les arméniens aronian sarkissian
les ukrainiens ivantchouk korobov les
azéris mamediarov radjabov les indiens à
nom de vie dit
les allemands ce van wagner est les
polonais duda vosges taceq les casaques
qui auront joua baïev et mur tu as donc
voila et nous la france
alors attendez un les gens bien qui
ronge obama et pande soulaya donc je
vous dis juste les à main les iraniens
qui auront max ou de louer ghalem les
croates qui auront saric jeu buzios itx
j'ai juste et deux premiers échiquiers
hommes parce qu'après femmes et juniors
vous pouvez - connaître et nous la
france
le pérou sera plus fort que nous
puissions cordova et cory et ils ont la
soeur de cory chez les filles
[Musique]
ok donc 45e le bangladesh sera plus fort
que nous monaco sera plus fort que la
france d'ailleurs
d'après ce que je vois voilà la france
on sera 60e donc moins fort que monaco
on aura maori 10 au premier et
razafindrabe simao 2 à huy donc en lots
rapide âgées plus des locaux quoi c'est
extraordinaire parce que ce sera rapide
la compétition ah oui j'aurais pu
afficher numéro un de l'équipe de france
a c'est terrible elle même si j'ai pas
vu depuis longtemps de façon mon équipe
mon lots rapides et meilleurs
bon ils sont plus forts que moi puisque
marquant qui est quand même plus fort
comment rapide et à des timothée aussi
mais c'est vrai qu'au lots en fait
j'aurais été choqué numéro un c'est
terrible c'est terrible quand ils france
ça c'est beau quoi donc échiquier et
chic et féminin en aura un à la fra oui
et solana fera oui donc deux joueuses
pas mal en échec et juniors garçons aux
ratés aubry si donc il joue pas mal et
juniors filles mathilde broulis qui joue
pas mal et remplaçants on aura marie ce
bague ne sera pas titulaire mais qui
pourra rentrer donc alors on travaille
sur une sur l'échiquier femmes et
évidemment elle sera forte et florence
rôle au brouillage pas comment ça se
présente
mais ok si vous comparez la line up dont
terre si on joue contre une équipe on va
dire la russie on aurait maori dit au 1
contre gries tchouk timoteo 2 contre
yann nepomniachi aux trois katyal
haguenau contre ana la fra oui aux
quatre guerriers âge qui n'a contre
ceux-là nafkha oui si je les ai mis dans
le bon ordre désolé si je me suis trompé
aux cinq on aurait six pieds au contre
contre théo et aussi ce jeu me rappelle
et mathilde broly contre shuvalova donc
ok autant dire qu'on a entre 400 et 500
points lot de moins sur chaque échiquier
c'est terrible contre la chine du coup
il aurait dingli renault 1 et wailly
enfin en fait on est on est
enfin monaco est favori contre nous quoi
c'est quand même terrible c'est terrible
donc je sais pas honnêtement si on
suivra cette équipe de france
j'en discuterai avec chasse comme mais
bon ça me ok ça me paraît difficile
sans vouloir sans vouloir manquer de
respect aux joueurs participant pas ce
qu'ils font ils font ce qu'ils peuvent
avec et si j'avais joué par exemple
baraf hockey joyeux lecomte great food
par exemple mais et c'est dur quand même
fort je peux rien y faire
ça doit être réelle ou pas qui défend
nos couleurs mais c'est vrai que celui
d'une équipe de france comme ça c'est
pas forcément je sais pas si pour vous
c'est intéressant mais ça me paraît un
peu enfin je pense que même le
turkménistan est favori contre nous
mêmes la butte belgique doit être plus
forte
à quoi qu'ils ont les filles sont
vraiment faibles bon mais c'est juste
difficile de suivre quoi
ces problèmes pour ses joues pas non non
je sais pas un fort et demandé qu'en
france et j'aime en ont décidé de pas
jouer doit y avoir des raisons ça après
ça les regarde mes yeux qu'est même
singapour de mettre une fessée peut-être
à quoi que chez les petits sont pas très
forts et guatemala on doit être plus
fort je regardais un petit peu un la
syrie on est plus forts l'angola quel
angola on est quand même bien favori
aussi l'irak
ouais non l'irak en fait on est favoris
chez les jeunes contre ce genre de pays
nicaragua on sera favori dominique
républicaine aussi contre le kosovo non
ça va en fait chez les jeunes sahara qui
est la zambie peut être dangereuse
sans ma visite hadji qui s'en alla
malaga scaër à 20 da gascard peut être
dangereux non mais ça doit aller ça doit
aller confié pays comme ça se doit les
noms quand même non non ça doit aller on
parle des olympiades en parle un peu
désolant cas de jojo's 5
on en profite puisque le maroc et le
match a un grand intérêt puisqu'on va
savoir qui et quatre troisièmes du du
quatrième grand prix fille de féminin
sur internet donc évidemment un match au
sommet mais on profite du calme du match
pour la troisième place pour discuter un
peu de ces olympiades et pour regarder
un peu les listes des joueurs ouais mais
bon après on peut créer des surprises
sont des grosses équipes on a des bons
jeunes mais en gros on n'aura pas face
et pas une nouvelle baky aux uns et aux
deux quoi est ce que chaque assuré paye
et plus fort d'afrique et je pense
algérie maroc tunisie ça va être pas mal
et après chance pays comme la zambie ou
quoi ils ont ils ont quelques bons
joueurs
non mais contre la russie oui c'est plus
fin c'est impossible en fait
mais en gros ouais je sais pas si pour
vous ce sera intéressant à suivre ou pas
mais enfin moi je puis dire que là
l'équipe de france en en l'occurrence
comme ça ça peut pas passer juste un peu
triste quoi et l'egypte aussi oui oui
oui j oubliais is moule des meilleurs
pays au monde c'est chine russie etats
unis inde
non ça enfin un petit personnage fou que
c'est un peu un peu triste de pas ne pas
avoir les meilleurs même si ce n'est pas
tout les meilleurs tu peux pas comme
beaucoup de grands maîtres de qualité en
france mais tu peux avoir une équipe
très décente en sortant de mv lé ba qui
donc est h 4 d'accord donc là on a
toujours on a cette italienne à ce jus
qu'au piano mais a le x 7 qui est bien
un qui est bien enterrée
les doutes je pense qu'on aurait pu
faire quelque chose dans ce tournoi non
je pense qu'on aurait quand même eu du
mal à jouer la gagne
ce que le truc c'est que tu as des
nations comme la russie et la chine qui
chez les hommes seront pas moins forts
que nous ce genre tu prends la chine
dingli renault et c'est pas moins bien
que amv el baki voire même mieux et
après chez les filles oui les fans
jouent and june ça fait quand même très
mal à ces mêmes su mais marie et sophie
ou pauline ok oui dit fan des jouets jun
c'est quand même au dessus c'est quand
même les deux plus fortes femmes au
monde est derrière chez les juniors les
chinois ils sont pas très connu mais
généralement ils ont des petits lots il
joue que en chine mais ils sont très
bons et beaux 10h10 les jets milo zf de
ce tournoi et c'est normal enfin tous
les autres pays ont les meilleurs à tu
regardes la réussite tu regardes la
chine je regarde les états unis à tata
des très grosses équipes
après ça c'est un autre débat je sais
pas je ne suis pas du tout occupé de
commandes ont été sélectionnés les
joueurs ou quoi mais dans les autres
pays tu as les meilleurs joueurs
voitures gardent toute la liste à
quasiment tous les pays qui ont pas
forcément le 1 et le 2 mai qui ont pire
le 5 et le 6 bon donc les noirs et sarah
qui trouve un peu d' attaque
ouais je pense que si on suit ça on
suivra plutôt les matches des autres
équipes exactement is moule je suis moi
je suis plutôt pour suivre un match tu
vois russie arménie par exemple ça ça va
envoyer une ukraine azerbaïdjan puisque
ukraine vivent en dessous korobov
afficher les filaos maquiller et hf
tchenko peut-être tu vas avoir des gros
matches il y aura des gros matches à des
grosses équipes
enfin à la pologne taghane tout d'abord
est à sec
enfin tu vas avoir des matches
intéressants
et du coup j'ai plus envie de me
focaliser sur ces matchs si on si on
suit ces olympiades qui est à mon avis
seront sont des matchs vraiment
intéressants plutôt que sur une équipe
de france un peu écho plus quoi une
nouvelle fois pas de souci avec les
joueurs qui feront le mieux qu'ils
peuvent
mais bon ils sont forcément moins fort
que les que les meilleurs français
ça c'est pas leur manquer de respect que
de le dire
ouais du coup côté france nos deux
premiers jours ce qu'on deux jeunes on
aura marque andriat donc s'écouler on
aura
le petit théo et je veux par prononcer
son nom parce qu'il est long et
compliqué le petit timothée pardon parce
que son nom et est long et compliqué
mais mais on aura des deux bons jeunes
joueurs mais c'est loin de mvf bacrot et
capitaine de l'équipe sera mathilde
choisi du coup mais leurs lots alors en
rapide en lentilles sont 2450 je crois
pour marquant et 2003 quelque chose je
crois pour timothée laon rapides ils
sont 2002 mais comme ils sont jeunes ça
veut pas dire grand chose mais bon
évidemment 2004 et 2003 c'est loin de
2800 et 2700 donc elles filent un pion
mais je crois que c'est la dernière
partie de la cadence non non les petits
sont bons cicb des bons jeunes mais face
à gries choo que face à greek food
nepomniachi c'est quand même dur quoi
est là il va y avoir tout recettes enfin
deux variantes et il ya un pion qui va
tomber mais à tourcoing fc est allé faut
le prendre ce pion pour yifan mais sur
ces cinq la tour f 5 noms et la tour c 7
il faut monter le roi c'est bien joué ah
oui il ya un hypocrite ou qu en face
puis en plus on n'a pas les meilleurs
chez chaînon dans rien en fait
donc c'est terrible c'est terrible bon
alors il faut que yi fan trouve la
technique pour gagner les prises prise
l'inria junior et la tourbe et si ce nom
qui gagne nos meilleurs juniors
justement voilà finale de play
complètement gagnante un tu prends et ya
le pion f qui va à dame et j'imagine
c'était la dernière partie de la cadence
et donc ce match qui va qui va tourner
pour le moment à une mis un an et demi
oui fans qui a égalisé donc on aura cinq
minutes de pause maintenant et on
reprendra donc on reprend dans dans cinq
minutes je vais vous mettre la pub et on
se retrouvera donc comme ça ça m'a
permis de parler un peu des olympiades
c'est déjà ça et on se retrouve on se
retrouve dans cinq petites minutes a de
suite les mecs je repasse la dernière
partie est en rapide
à
alors j'espère que je n'ai pas trop
manqué les gars on est de retour
donc
on va repartir bientôt les jouets ce
qu'ils reviennent aussi mais ça les a
wind waker 6-3 saluton dont m'ont donc
ça on a quand même eu l'occasion d'un
petit peu parlé de ces olympiades donc
on est d'accord sur sur le délire
d'essayer de faire une demande pas pour
suivre l'équipe de france mais mais on
est on est tous d'accord si je demande
plutôt de farah bien qu'il ya un peu de
réactions du chat là c'est un peu des
gens même si je me doute que c'est pas
le le live le plus suivi de l'histoire
des live mais mais on est d'accord c'est
plus intéressant de suivre les top teams
que notre équipe de france après je veux
pas enfin je sais qu'en disant ça je
vous force voulait forcément un biais
cognitif mai donc n'hésitez pas si vous
êtes contre c'est toi qui sais ce que tu
n'as rien disons qu'une équipe de france
sans joueur du top du top 20 ou du top
30 dans l'équipe ça me moi ça ça me rend
un peu triste quapla titre personnel je
sais pas vous mais moi ça me rend un peu
triste d'aller suivre l'équipe de france
qui va se battre pour la 70e place alors
que en alignant notre équipe top on joue
top 10 et on peut même jouer le titre si
ça se passe bien quoi je trouve ça
dommage parce c'est moi juste ça me va
je regarde toujours les équipes en tant
que supporter tu as c'est comme si je
vais commencer à regarder la coupe davis
et au lieu d'avoir
mon fils benoît paire et tsonga je me
retrouve avec des joueurs aux alentours
de la 50e place mondiale
ça me rend triste en fait après c'est
peut-être mon côté supporters en fait de
l'équipe et qui me donne toujours envie
de voir la france gagne et d'être à fond
derrière mais juste une équipe de france
comme ça ça me ça me déprime un peu quoi
ça me déprime un peu à titre personnel
donc je sais pas comment vous êtes vous
mais moi ça me voilà tu peux te suivre
les grands matchs équipe de france qu'il
n'y aura pas de grosses rencontres
oui mais y aura pas de gros matches pour
l'équipe de france fragile 94 c'est
impossible
tu peux pas avoir un gros match si t'as
pas ne pas même pas un grand maître dans
l'équipe
donc c'est terrible et non je ne sais
pas pourquoi on a on est une équipe
comme ça recaro il faudra demander faire
faudrait faudra avoir de raison
officielle
mais c'est comme au foot si on prenait
une équipe de ligue 2 où des joueurs de
national en fait ça ressemblera à ça ah
oui excuse-moi fragile 94 g m'a lu ton
truc tu dis tu peux suivre le gros match
de l'équipe de france et l'équipe de
france quand il n'y a pas de grosses
rencontres
ah oui excuse moi j'ai pas bien lu
désolé désolé désolé frage 94 g m'a lu
ton message
j'ai lu de l'équipe de france et j'ai
pas lu et l'équipe de france en essayant
de lire vite j'ai mal lu
mais oui on peut faire ça mais y aura
des gros matches tout le temps en fait
du coup en réalité il y aura toujours un
gros match parce que il ya minimum dix
grosses équipes
en tout cas si cette équipe qui joue
vraiment le titre et il y aura toujours
des grands matchs
c'est une compétition où la nature même
de la compet fait qu'il ya forcément des
gros matches non-stop
bon mais du coup on est peu mais j'ai
l'impression que vous êtes plutôt
d'accord avec moi après c'est vrai que
j'ai mis un gros biais cognitifs en
donnant mon avis au début ce qui n'est
jamais bon
mais d'un autre côté de mon avis me
paraît tellement logique mais c'est
quand même suspect assure l'équipe de
france de foot etc tu va galérer pour
battre andorre et san marin pas ça va
être triste quoi et tu as et tu prends 6
0 contre le brésil
alors que si tu alignes m bape et
griezmann et tout ça tu la mets à tout
le monde quoi
ouais l'équipe de france
moi je pense que t'as aucun joueur du
top 30 qui joue quoi c'est quand même
dur
non mais même l'italie est bien plus
forte que nous ah mais c'est terrible
c'est terrible l'angleterre bien plus
regard même l'angleterre il aligne adams
mcshane non mais c'est m
c'est terrible elle vient thème bleu via
tam a une belle équipe un ils ont le
coup anglais mais une guyenne derrière
ils ont femmes l'état olala fils à vous
rappeler les et hoang thi bas au tram
qui est bien aussi et juniors ils ont un
autre ennemi vianney bart van gogh thuy
duong et je pense qu'ils sont bons mais
ils ont une équipe sympa ils ont trân
minh aussi tang qui joue pas mal sur
autre chose comme ça ils ont une belle
équipe même le vietnam quoi ils sont
peuvent être dangereux quoi à israël a
une belle équipe aussi rothstein mirin
sympa je file girl ioulia et cleanova
goro jet ski en juniors et 4 kof
juniors filles que je connais pas ah ils
ont ils ont abate en remplaçant chez les
hommes
non non il ya des belles équipes
il ya des belles équipes
donc on a une position d'ouest indienne
avec ce fou en bessin contre le fu g2 ce
pion des cinq dons qui est sur la ligne
de conflits de la diagonale et ça joue
un peu comme un ben coop tatev 4,5 qui
peut être un plan qui avait laissé
quatre fois f4 pour taper sur le pion
des six ça peut être deux idées
différentes qui peuvent être mises à
jour ouais c'est clair que pour être
belle et baky c'est plus important de
préparer les candidats qui vont arriver
après il n'y a pas que mv à l'eba qui en
grand maître français le le fait qu'elle
m'avait l'eba qui joue pas ça mon avis
cet acte est d' avance parce que avec
avec les candidats en ligne de mire
encore que nepomniachi va jouer pour la
russie mais il sera plus remplaçant
peut-être que titulaire
est ce que j'ai déjà affronté des
joueurs en compétition j'ai déjà à jouer
williams a zo par exemple bah voilà pour
donner un exemple maso dans le genre
grands maîtres français mais bon après
peut-être que ça n'intéresse pas de
jouer je sais pas combien d'argent a été
proposée pour jouer etc
c'est aussi souvent une question une
question d'argent aussi un tu peux pas
faire jouer des joueurs professionnels
pendant pendant plus d'une dizaine de
jours
tous les jours gratuitement c'est pas
c'est pas possible
est-ce que kosteniuk a perdu non la
finale ce sera un petit peu après à ces
malfrats troisième place à yas fab
mais tu peux pas faire jouer maso
cornette fabu quoi gratuitement donc ça
peut aussi dépendre des conditions
offertes aux joueurs pas c'est normal
c'est normal quand tu demandes à des
joueurs professionnels de jouer même si
c'est pour jouer pour leur pays c'est
normal qu'ils aient une rémunération
si je pensais que ça à pied à la finale
elle va commencer vers 16h à la et qui
prend des 5,4 terrible assez terrible le
clouage f4 grosse faute fallait faire
tour un break et prend des cinq vu un
parent ou ifan femme n'a pas fait la
section bains honnêtement je ne sais pas
combien étaient étaient proposées pour
joueurs mais honnêtement même moi si tu
proposes jour en équipe de france comme
ça gratuitement c'est loin d'être sûr
que j'accepte juste tout travail mérite
rémunération tout de même même si tu
défends ton pays c'est on ne peut plus
juste pas vivre en fait ça faut payer le
loyer il ya ici à des problèmes
financiers
combien joueurs pros comme fabienne dans
ce genre de débat n'ont pas j'imagine ça
dépend des pays
win wind waker combien les pays payent
pas moi c'est dur de dire combien je
demanderai pour un tel tournoi dans le
sens où je suis plus professionnel mais
j'imagine qu'un joueur pro face à dépend
du niveau mais ça va forcément coûter
une certaine somme de bloquer quelqu'un
professionnels dix jours
ces voix là je sais pas à quelle qui se
demande exactement mais un joueur quand
même vl
il va pas de faire gratuit c'est sûr
c'est normal
y'a d'la prépare à des vies dans leur
lit sandales et évidemment pour jouer
dix jours à haut niveau et cetera
il ya énormément de préparation en
suisse dépend du niveau mais un mec
quand même vlc ça doit beaucoup chiffre
est un mec comme fable c'est beaucoup
moins cher c'est évident lorelei a
peut-être dame prend un équilibre en
bessin qu elle va tout jouer sur le pion
des six ça bien pour la dia pas de prix
d'ailleurs il ne joue plus assez chiant
parce qu'en fait je peux pas défendre
ton pions c'est marrant parce que je
pense que ça arrivait cette situation de
manière incongrue
je pense pas qu'elle ait fait exprès
sarah sa date mais la position est hyper
complexe a du mal à l'aise food et 4 et
sur walf un tour de tourbe des f2 et sur
roy h1 tourer oui non mais évidemment
aussi demander à quelqu'un qui est 5e
mondial où quelqu'un qui est 5 100e
mondiale de faire la même chose c'est
pas le même prix ouais donc plusieurs
gaffes là dans cette partie du sahara
qui maintenant est mené au score 2 1
pour la joueuse iranienne et ce soir on
aura la soupe battle contre les jazz
bras là tu peux faire b5 tu perds pas
maintenant encore mais tu peut parfois
avoir des fous prend f2 et tourcoing
enfin deux variantes dans le problème
c'est que tu es b 5 à bab vous prend
vous prend au roi prendre tout reprend
il ya souffrance et 6 à la fin de
cavalli serait plus défendu
tu as déjà tout le monde pour l'essab
batteur la sélection l'a fait toujours
une demi-heure avant donc la sélection
sera à partir de 20h contre lecce ce
bras
donc à alléger quatre cavalières ici
c'est une manoeuvre pour jouer avec 9,5
mais les autres joueurs n'ont pas de
palma le prendre soin des enfants au
premier comme la france est une grande
nation banon les autres joueurs ils vont
être contents de gagner un
mais après le truc c'est que oui enfin
forcément c'est triste
enfin c'est triste triste c'est pas le
mot mais c'est dommage de ne pas avoir
une équipe de france qui défende pas
chance quoi parce que c'est parce
qu'elle est un grand pays la france a
prêché un peu franchouillard des fois
mais mais c'est beau pays quand même des
chèques est en général assez calme la
france bordel c'est beau pays pas envie
de ça on a toujours envie de bien
défendre notre chance je pense au rang
des français quoi après c'est peut-être
moi qui suis un peu comme ça
donc puis j'ai acheté mais en fait tu
t'es détruit la structure 11 ans des
pions doublé mais ça te permet de
couvrir les lignes donc ça va être sympa
et ça lui accuse hans hama salut à toi
c'est la première fois que je vois dans
le chat donc bienvenu mais donc là avec
havas lieu cette dame f1 damev six
cavaliers 7 au g8 fou prend h3 tout ça
ça arrive c'est beaucoup plus sympa à
jouer pour les noirs cette histoire
nadal a bien joué gratuitement la beat
ringger prime et la busserine cup
c'était caritatif
c'était différent mais maxime a joué
pour là pour la bonne cause et d'heure
un grand grand grand merci à maxime
d'avoir participé à cet événement qui
est extraordinaire mais c'était c'était
pour la bonne cause c'est un événement
spécial pour devenir bon faut juste pas
me les game demande rendent au masters
il faut jouer pour être bon m et faut
travailler aussi n'hésite pas à les en
club ou déjà prendre un abonnement
diamant chaise comme tu auras pas mal de
deux choses auxquelles donne 17 mai elle
veut vite se diriger vers f4 avec
lecavalier mais est une tour en g8 ait
pu avoir le problème tu m'avais pas fait
5 à 20 fois que j'étais la duchesse
comme fer vrai mais je d'annales ça
dépend aussi ce qu'on commente un des
fois on est à fond dans la partie et
donc on regarde vraiment ce qui se passe
sur l'échiquier parfois on répond plus
au tchad ça dépend de de ce qui se passe
là on a un match
qui honnêtement on n'a absolument aucun
enjeu c'est vraiment n'y a aucun enjeu
donc ça fait aussi une différence
d'avoir un enjeu ou pas dans un match
quand ça joue des qualifications quoi
c'est une chose là c'est un match pour
la troisième place où les deux joueuses
sont déjà éliminés donc c'est fin c'est
vraiment un match avec absolument aucun
intérêt
c'est terrible proches commente alors
ben ça faut demander aux gens qui
veulent le commenter mais en soit ce
match a lieu juste parce qu'il a lieu
mais en gros 1
tu en as je vais répondre justement à
cheste comme pour les olympiades donc
tour d2 ah ok tu avais je demandé
à
je vais écrire en direct pour le honda
jazz comme ce qu'ils emportent du coup
attendez je vais demander ce qu'ils
m'ont répondu
je leur demandais au passage pour les
olympiades ce qu'ils en pensent ouais
c'est un échauffement pour pour la
finale donc à 10 h 4 jouer alors est-ce
qu'il va y avoir des 2/3 est ce qu'il va
y avoir des tours pranger 3 est-ce que
je blitz apreva comme j'ai dit aura le
solde battle ce soir à 20 heures donc si
ce live la fini à 18 heures je vais
peut-être faire une petite sieste après
et puis et puis oui on va formation tout
faire le sabbat talent ce speech ça se
passe bien la écoute on attend quand
même avec impatience le deuxième match
parce que là il y aura vraiment un
intérêt pour la peine kosteniuk pourrait
se qualifier là est peut-être tout
reprend j'ai deux sur l'étranger deux
dames pranger de maths
un coaching est là et on menace paquet
et pranger deux parce que c'est toujours
matin mais oui kosteniuk peut se
qualifier pour la grande finale
donc le deuxième match aura hélas et
étrangers 5 assez con quand même de
mettre la tour emprise bref c'est
dommage pour s'arrimer à tour en prise
en main est maintenant dame g4 c'est
bête hein tu es gentil tour g1 tanger 4
est jouable soit pas de contre
indication à yahvé dames 3 3 prises h
trois écueils pour un f3 pardon donc ça
c'est beaucoup mieux de la part de widi
fans voilà tout revient à enghien et ça
ça fait très mal parce que maintenant
c'est les blancs qui ont la tacc tour
j'ai deux menaces dame g8 a va faire f4
lecavalier s'en va alors dame g8 tour g8
ou reprend g8 y avait un clouage
auxquels fait dame f3 elle propose les
changes
moi j'aurais plutôt fait rage deux dames
4 hockey ahl attaque ici ou pas non
s'est défendue par don est peut-être
cavalier e 4 aussi gagné puis on prend
dame prend ok mais elle part pour le
tour g8 c'est bien jouer maintenant tour
g8 tout reprend g8 et si elle te fait
pas flyway l'a pas été déconnecté elle
réussit à à mater
donc ou qui fait le premier break 1 dans
ce match qui maintenant m 3 et mis un an
et demi
quand même bien ça rame et sarah qui est
qui une nouvelle fois dominé je crois
qu'elle a perdue elle a fini elle va
finir quatrièmes de tous les grands prix
qu'elle a joué sa rage et l'impression
elle est parti pour ne faire que des
quatrièmes plaza rubber lissant dalsky à
qui remarque la même chose que moi au
même moment
c'est marrant quand elle aura bien battu
les joueuses plus faible alors été très
efficace et quand elle tombe contre plus
forte en fait son jeu tactique ne passe
plus et du coup ça lui fait très très
mal
ouais sarasar assalat salat sa de la
semaine dernière sa dernière 4e place
pour apprendre vous le conseille plutôt
de faire les problèmes ou défaire des
parties contre ordinateur moi je propose
qu than sama de fer et des problèmes et
des parties contre d'autres joueurs mais
pas trop contre l'ordinateur je te
propose plutôt de jouer contre contre
d'autres d'autres humains
ouais sahara qui jouent à qui sait
peut-être cavaliers 5a qui est
intéressant car elle et prend pions
prend l'idée c'est que sur dame prend ya
dame prend ici petit piège
petit piège peut être sympa après juste
fou e2 aussi un elfe écailleuse 5
d'ailleurs bien joué
sa raquette mais qui a eu cinq peut-être
elle va prendre une fois et faire un
dames 6 ce qui sera à mon avis assez
logique de la part de la joueuse a
[Musique]
j'écris juste pour les olympiades
donc
donc dame g5 jouer là dessus c'est aussi
possible et sur h4 est le co à dammaj 5e
3 vous bougez regardez moi 2 jours hkd à
mach 5 f3 fou bouge à est sûre j'ai
katia dame 3,5 pardon pardon erreur de
la part du commentateur français elle a
fait du coup f4 dame hkd g3 hockey hall
et drilles se sait bien aussi sur chaise
comme ray tu parles à rennes je pars à
longages juste en dessous de règne en
fait c'est pas forcément lui qui décide
tout seul en fait parfois on peut
discuter de certaines je sors parfois ya
des choses qu'on est obligé de faire et
parfois des choses on peut discuter
voilà c'est le genre de truc dont on
peut discuter parce que c'est un cas un
petit peu spécial salut je me pose une
question à laquelle je sais pas répond
dit vaut mieux prendre un fou et
cavaliers et perdre une tour ou linverse
fouet cavaliers sont plus forts que tour
de loin généralement la le roi de sarah
sadate
il m'a l'air d'être un peu en danger il
ya plus de pions sur la deuxième ça peut
être hyper relou on va dire que dans 90%
des cas fou cavaliers sont plus forts
que tout revoir même que touré pions
donc
vous savez 5 jouer une menace tout prend
2,3 il va y avoir du fouet f3 qui va
arriver
et puis h3 et attaquer donc c'est galère
il ya des quatre aussi qui menace qui va
attaquer cavalier est fou
voilà donc je peux déjà vous dire que la
d4 des quatre le problème c'est qu'il a
pu engranger quatre attaques la dame par
contre donc c'est chaud ouais donc je
peux déjà vous dire que normalement on
suivra les équipes qui jouent la gagne
dans les olympiades et pas cette équipe
de france malgré le fait que j'adore
suivi l'équipe de france apparemment de
ce que j'ai lu je vous confirme le rsa
dans les jours à venir
mais apparemment on va on va se
focaliser sur sur les équipes de
premiers de premier rang et on jettera
peut-être des petits coups derrière la
france mais on va pas on va pas se faire
de mal
donc tour hd 1 et les olympiades ce sera
en août
peut-être pour s'éviter ces 5
non mais moi ça me fait trop de mal en
fait parce que je vis le truc à fond
depuis les compétitions à fond surtout
quand il ya la france et où je suis
hyper supporters et juste ça va me je
vais je être fou un moment donné on va
juste pour te dire en lots rapide bon
même s'il est plus fort que moi marquant
en fait
enfin j'aurais été échiquier numéro un
de l'équipe de france même si en terme
de niveau j'aurai pas les joueurs sont
un peu plus fort que moi il n'y a pas de
souci ça je veux bien le dire en termes
de niveaux ils sont vraiment plus fort
que moi il ya aucun aucun débat là
dessus en marquant et timothée sont bien
plus forts que moi en rapide mais en
juste allé lô c'est juste pour pour
faire un popov pour montrer un truc qui
entre guillemets qui choque comme dirait
vlad mais à mais j'aurais plus déloger
plus des lots que la foulée six noms
assez terrible de ne pas avoir vu la
l'enfilade ouais mais c'est terrible de
prendre fougue et 6 en trois points
d'écart mais les compétitions en équipe
vous montrerai ce soir si vous voulez
sur bitstream
ouais sahara en sueur sarah en vrai en
vrai sur la déjà trois points d'écart le
score qui enfle et en bis que je suis
meilleur non je pense pas je me sens un
peu plus fort que moi mais bon
l'écart est pas énorme quoi papa comme
avec 1 1
baky encore en étau
pourquoi alors ces six four b3 peut-être
un des cinq qui va arriver pour les
noirs voilà c'est chose faite
positions sont jamais simples et noir
réussissent à jouer des cinq en premier
donc ils prennent le centre mais le
centre qui peut être vulnérable par la
suite
il me semble n'avait pas forcément
beaucoup d'affinités à deux avec qui tu
parles samir us dax sahara
malheureusement je la connais pas plus
que ça
marco il a 14 ans et marquant il est
super fort il va être super forts avec
les représentants de la france
ah mais c'est pas une question
d'affinités et enfin ils vont faire ce
qu'ils peuvent ils vont descendre
défendre leur chance comme ils peuvent
samir us et je leur souhaite de faire le
meilleur résultat qui preuve très
sincèrement mais juste j'espère qu'ils
joueront bien et qui font des bons
matchs qu'ils apprendront et que ça les
fera progresser et c'est juste c'est dur
et merci que santana qui vous souhaite
une bonne journée bonne journée à toi
bon dimanche
non il ya ce gros centres faut faire
gaffe de ne pas perdre le pion de saint
caprais fou prend à 7.7 qui comprend des
cinq puis on prend des cinq tours prend
1,5 à ce soir wind waker 63 ciao ciao
aller puis on prend un tour prend 2,5
donc qui arrive
et qui va faire un pion de plus pour
pour ou qui va peut-être peut-être juste
gagner le match dans les trois minutes
1,6 a réussi à bien tenir là elle fait
un bon match oui fans
elle fait un très bon match où elle mène
au score c'est plutôt bien ce qu'elle
fait
c'est plutôt bien ce qu'elle fait pour
le moment
si vous êtes nouveau d'ailleurs à suivre
la chaîne n'hésitez pas à mettre un
petit follow vous pouvez aussi suivre ma
chaîne perso vous avez lien juste en
dessous pourquoi les patrons aussi ce
alors j'ai l'impression que tout le long
et à lecavalier a quatre qui la défend
ce pion aux six terrine de sanglier
elles ont juste à perdre et la tour qui
se ferait qu elle capture et donc ça
doit être l'avant dernière partie dans
cette cadence
ça va être l'avant dernière partie dans
cette cadence mais à tour ans et 6
il reste combien de temps fou ces deux
elle revient elle revient à s'activer
donc c'est un pion de plus un mais mais
ça reste chaud il reste quatre minutes
dans la cadence si on aura y aura encore
une partie derrière et salua roux 23 ans
a essayé de venir en h7
j'aimerais aussi des tours f3 qui
peuvent rodez pour venir couper le roi
et quand tu rentres en achetant des
cavaliers h5 par la suite jean retour
est froid et tous les trois ça peut être
fort tu menaces cavale et h5 d'un match
7 et gagner ça ça ça peut faire le point
ça c'est genre de coûts qui peuvent
faire le point plus sarah est mal autant
qu'elle prend h trois échecs et roy f1
aurait bien joué car il ya 4 et
maintenant damage cette cave alliage 5
ou cavaliers h5 d'abord ça va faire le
point à la le temps découle d'un match 4
il va y avoir damage 7 et cavaliers pour
un f4 dans les tours pour un f4 même qui
va faire une double attaque et qui gagne
carrément la dame du coup dans cette
variante là et ça fait plus 4 donc oui
fans là maintenant normalement il reste
quatre parties elle a besoin d'une nulle
sur quatre partis pour remporter le
match de la troisième place
mon cas est ce le rliss sandales ce
sahara mené au score oui mais elle est
beaucoup moins forte que son adversaire
ça ce ça se voit elle arrive pas à
lutter oui fans qu'il avait déjà battu
la semaine dernière de mémoire mais là
vu le scénario du match j'ai envie de
dire il n'y a pas grand suspense bombe
d'un retour est toujours possible mais
vu la domination et le score là qui
enfle ça paraît hautement improbable et
des donc mais bon c'est pas voilà c'est
comme ça c'est surtout la finale qu'on
est venu voir avec kosteniuk donc qui en
cas de qualifications jouera demain en
finale contre vous chez nina et si
kosteniuk perd ce sera guy nadon qui
jouera contre auch et nina boch et nina
qui va essayer de d'employer le système
de londres à tout va avec les blancs
pour battre l'une des deux joueuses
russes
moi peut-être rock elle prend des 4l
jouer contre le pion isoler fort régler
le problème du fou est ce que paie cissé
joie pour fou bessette
elle fait fou 17,4 m une tour ans et 8
ans des huit le fond à 8
c'est du classique mais vraie sarah mon
avis qui sait que le match est derrière
elle on peut faire tous rêvent des 8 es
fou 1,8 avec elle prend aux cinq dames
g5 1 4 dames 7
elle a provoqué f4 pour affaiblir le roi
c'est peut-être bien joué
tout cas où qui a l'air d'être très
tranquille et ça rassure
dans cette dernière partie de la cadence
un peu de musique en dehors de chez moi
dame prend prise
tours s'est vite attaque le fou puis à 6
ça a l'air d'être complètement légal
aujourd'hui ou pitt-jolie aeberli
sandales ce peut-être un fou b5 possible
à tout moment pour fixer et puis avant
ça devrait nous mener vers une nulle
cette position-là petit à petit et la
nulle gagne quasiment le match on sera à
99.99 % de gains tout cas ça pas de
déconnexion
autour des cases mais le fou en b 5
comme prévu tour d un tour des huit on
échange tout le long de la colonne la
tête pour ses 7 ans et 8 jouables un
petit coup de hache si ceux-ci jouable
fait autour des 8 elle va échanger
autour des intrants des quatre tours
prend des quatre tours c8 et tour c'est
un tour b 1
pour ces six nous faire tomber 6 pouces
et 6
ça va gagner face à gagner ça va gagner
le match je veux dire ça va pas perdre
en fait comme comme une mule doit gagner
le match
c'est pour ça que dans mon esprit fair
nul pour ou mais synonyme de victoire on
a du mal à la voir perdre ou est là elle
peut commencer à voir g3 g4 à 5
peut-être ta g 5 aussi qui est
intéressant pour miner le centre naha 5
donnent carrément vient de gagner le
pion même si c'est pas sûr qu'il puisse
le conserver elle fait tour à 6
je suis étonné par ce coup on va changer
les tours pour ce qu'elle fera 5 pour
gagner le pion mais ce n'était pas
forcément le pion pouvait être perdu 1
je pense qu'à mettre le pion des six
soit et attendre
bon ça va ça va bientôt s'arrêter cette
partie j'imagine
parce que là tu peux pour un poème et
prendre prendre tu fais g6 et y'a jamais
devions passer à gfg g6 et je pense
qu'il ya aucune porte d'entrée par
contre important de faire juger si c'est
parce que si vous faites pas g6 vous
allez vous prendre h 5 h 6 et le pion
pas s'éloigner alors qu'en faisant g6 ça
permet de s'assurer que sur h5 qu'on
puisse toujours échangées donc ça comme
je vous disais c'est complètement
al'avantage de ou
fier de faire nul caisse a ras le seul
truc pour essayer c'est de faire sa sas
arrivants g7 avec le roi et faire foi je
sais tu fous g8 mes trucs super roi f8
tu vas jamais y arriver
tu va échanger et sûrs mêleront e7 est
maintenant je crois qu'il ya même plus
une seule idée de gains ok ça aurait que
tu peux essayer de passer le roi en b 5
mais n'a jamais y arriver en fait
qui es là tu échanges
férois csis les rois 17 caisses est pas
idiot ce qu'elle fait ça ok moi j'ai 6
airwatch ci soit ya jamais de caste
d'entrée mais ce pas idiot parce qu'elle
sait garder les coûts d'attendre sahara
c'est bien ce qu'elle a tenté ça mais
voilà bon résultat pour iphone c'est nul
ça lui permet de fermer la cadence 3 + 1
avec 4 points d'avance et le match doit
être plié là les amis à mon avis donc on
va refaire comme tout à l'heure pour la
pause on va se passer la dernière partie
en entier et on reviendra dans 5 minutes
pour suivre le bullet mais surtout
surtout pour aller sur la finale la
grande finale qui alors un intérêt réel
là le match est déjà plié donc petite
pause et on se retrouve pour la grande
finale a de suite les gars
m
je suis de retour pour pour le bullet
qui a juste repris je me suis fait
dépasser je regardais sur le live mais
j'ai oublié qu'il y avait un petit
décalage de cinq secondes
de toute façon le match est terminé donc
on va rien on n'a rien raté puisque
puisque de toute façon quoi qu'il se
passe dans ses parties ça ne changera
absolument rien le match est déjà plié
donc on va attendre
on va attendre tranquillement les dix
minutes du speech s bullet ailleurs un
de 45 personnes
merci pour le raid du coup et je vais
rater mais bon de toute façon là on n'a
aucun aucun intérêt à suivre ça on ira
voir le prochain on va attendre le
prochain match tranquillement donc j'ai
enlevé les caméras en fait je vous
rappeler un peu l'enjeu 2
de la finale entre conejo et alexandra
kosteniuk donc
un petit koné rouelle qui va jouer pour
gagner un speech est quand même donc bon
il ya un petit peu d'argent je vais
surtout alexandra alexandra kosteniuk
qui elle va jouer pour pour une
éventuellement une éventuelle
qualification pour la finale et du cou
et du cou ouais ouais non là y aura pour
la finale pour la peine ya un vrai il ya
un vrai enjeu là c'est pas une blague
lier un vrai enjeu pour pour le dernier
match
bon ici normalement le match est
complètement terminé à moins ce qui est
des parts à moins qu'il ait des parties
très rapide mais bon là de toute façon
avec cette partie là est déjà beaucoup
trop longue
parce que pour qu'il y ait que trois
parties faudrait jeu des parties courtes
et que ça rajouterait vite mais sarah ne
jouent pas très vite
et en plus c'est loin d'être dit qu'elle
gagne
which has comme chez screen de nous
sortir son regard de tueuse encore elle
va pas gagner en plus sarah ça s'active
ça va prendre le pion bessette tout va
s'échanger et ça va faire annuler
est-ce que c'est chez non ça c'est une
mauvaise question j'ai bien fait pas la
lire bon allez on va voir comment ça
évolue tour de tourbe et 4 c 5 à 4 tours
5 échecs montre de toute façon ça doit
rester toujours nul mais bon là la
partie durant + mas de coûts donc c'est
sûr maintenant qui en aura pas plus de
trois parties j'aimerais presse 4 on va
dépasser les 5 minutes de jeu sur
celle-là faut faire tourner ici ça a
joué des plombes avec le pion f à tour h
6 e tour j'ai six échecs
non moi j'ai deux mois les ça va on va
faire tout re 2 pour couper le roi bon
la cadence la c1 plus sains et chez
steurs à wemmel va se prendre fkt
finalement y'a pas elle aura pas mis la
tour en f3 n'a pas réussi à bloquer et
ça elle va même la perdre au final cette
finale n'était pas forcément si simple à
défendre en bullet mais là ça va aller
vers un lycée n'a donc oui fans qui en
plus va encore alourdir le score
après la bonne nouvelle pour sarah c'est
qu'il va pas y rester il reste déjà plus
de cinq minutes à jouer
donc ça va pas durer très longtemps
comme dirait mur tu as il lui reste deux
parties mais ça aurait été vraiment un
match à sens unique à ouilly fan pourra
vraiment dominé de a à z elle était
juste plus forte dans tous les
compartiments du jeu le petit jeu
tactique à la dominer les ouvertures
c'était plutôt pas mal aussi pour où
le bullet là-bas forcément elle domine
puisqu'elle mène au score
nantes où tout s'est bien passé pour ou
cavaliers b4 qui est hyper pénible
oulalala il ya cavaliers detroit qui
menacent mattia qui avait laissé deux il
ya les débits mans les déviations pardon
avec fou prend f3 les débits mais ça ça
a plus trop pour moi et ça à pouvoir
encore alourdir rep adams est juste sur
feu de fou prend un f3 il ya le clouage
et sur dame de fou prend à f3 ça va
faire 8 2 ça va faire 8 de cavaliers 5
milliards francs h 1 à 3 et cavaliers c6
le retour
elle réussit à créer une menace pénible
elle se fait changer et grand roque
peut-être manqué 17 pions de 5 en l'air
ça devrait pas durer très longtemps mais
bien joué ou un bien joué à new york et
détroit qui prend b2 puisque c'est sur
double échec faut le voir encore un
espace facile moi j'ai le petit ordi là
j'ai un peu flemmard là pour cette fin
de match où qui a réfléchi ou qui se
prend la tête
après c'est pas évident un parfois de
l'eau peut-être tofu prend f3 elle
ferait froid ça paraît cool elle fait
d'amd si ce défaut bref trois maintenant
améliora dame prend 1,5 vous prend au
caloy elle va rentrer du matériel pressé
dit c'est pas pas facile une fois que le
match est gagné de rester complètement
focus façon est là elle a cinq points
d'avance t'es là on va être sur une
partie qui dure de toutes manières ou la
lie à tour s est tu n'en as fou des cinq
échecs croix b 8 qu'elle réussit et
c'est bien joué là de la part de sa mère
un retour 17 foods 6
elle menace tout reprend ses sept donc
faut peut-être faire roi des huit mois
c'est chose faite
sarah qui récupère le matériel mais bon
une nouvelle fois cinq points d'écart
alors j'ai un peu enlevé les calmes
parce que je veux je veux garder le le
machin de la finale la fij la finale à
l'écran donc ce comme j'en parle un peu
au début comme de toute façon ce match
et est terminée je peux vous remettre un
petit peu les calmer
ça va continuer ça peut jouer longtemps
ça
rg c'est non mais c'est terrible hein
c'est terrible final fausses couleurs
opposable peut-être qu'on peut réussir à
voir que deux parties en bullet jeu
c'est la première fois que je
commenterai un match avec seulement deux
parties je peste est déjà arrivé mais si
cette partie dure énormément de coups
parce que si ça dure 60 coup ça rajoute
une minute deux minutes on pourrait
arriver
allez oui fans qui replace son roi ok
c'est bien joué parce que le truc c'est
que tu peux mettre ton rang à schwyz où
h6 et attendre ce qu'on arrête même si
ta copions h est fou contre roye ça va
faire nul donc elle peut aller gagner le
fou si elles souhaitent soit oui fans
kia qui a fait le bon set up on la voit
à la caméra elle sait que c'est nul
total
mais après peut-être que sarah pour
qu'ils aient moins deux parties va faire
durer le truc
au moins on se fatigue pas sarah qui
propose nul c'est accepter aller dans
les yeux que deux parties en bullet
voilà ils ont joué une partie longue ce
qui a permis de d'économiser une partie
entre guillemets qui j'imagine n'était
pas n'était pas voulu ni par lui ni par
l'autre victoire très facile d'ouilly
fans set et demi à cinq et demi ou qui
aura totalement dominé la rencontre et
qui l'emportent assez facilement et donc
on va pouvoir démarrer là finale donc
avec l'enjeu si kosteniuk se qualifie
elle participera à la grande finale
sinon ce sera valentina goût nina est à
mon avis kosteniuk et grosses favori de
cette finale j'avais déjà miss favorite
à partir des quarts déjà kosteniuk et on
va voir un si elles l'emportent et si
j'avais vu juste
on verra
alors que dans l'autre match un pic au
nehru n'est pas encore arrivé piccone
roux est en retard
on va voir je vais attendre que les
choses arrivent
allen vient d'arriver un petit rôle à se
mettre du côté d' homme qui allait donc
les jouets ce qu'ils font là qu'ils sont
en train de montrer pour le moment à
l'écran leur environnement alexandra moi
j'avais déjà mises favorite bien avant
de ce dernier grand prix
allez on va voir les joueuses alexandra
kosteniuk on compterait mme pico nero
c'est le match qui nous intéresse
maintenant la finale
alors attendez je vais les suivre à
leurs côtés m puis on va se mettre au
tapis
voilà enfin ce maître côté côté joueuses
non favorite alors 6ème qui veut
l'emporter il faudra vraiment quelle
qu'elles qu'elles fassent l'écart à mon
avis dans le 5 + 1 et le 3 + 1 en bullet
alexandra doit être vraiment plus forte
faudrait au moins qu'elle tourne avec +1
à mon avis des deux premières cadence
mais là ça va être un match sympa comme
je vous disais il ya une qualif en jeu
pour la grande finale et donc c'est
assez c'est assez intéressant à suivre
on va dire la petite finale était un
échauffement qui finalement nous a pas
fait tant vibrer que sahin
malheureusement mais sur la finale on a
espoir sur la finale on n'a plus espoir
j'ai envie de dire
elle revient de loin alexandra ouais
mais bon elle est forte elle est forte
en bullet hell est forte en tout
alexandra elle est complète
moi je la mets favorite après c'est
peut-être 65 35
c'est pas non plus c'est pas non plus
énorme
ouaip ump qui a un pic il fait une bonne
une bonne dernière un bon dernier grand
prix qui a commencé à s'habituer aux
joutes sur internet et qui pourraient
être dangereuses dans les prochaines
compétitions sur internet et même
aujourd'hui
allez c'est parti pour cette finale
alexandra qui ouvre par quatre cinq
cavaliers trois quarts ali hafsi sky
prend 1,5 à elle va jouer l'aller des
petrov aujourd'hui ump et alexandra qui
joue ça dans ta qali c3 qui est france
et 3 aider c'est donc pour ce faire des
pions doublé mais avec l'idée de jouer
après avec grand roque d'accélérer le
développement et éventuellement mettre
le pion c4 pour contrôler la casse des 5
et jouer un avantage des espaces grâce
aux options options c4 entre guillemets
et le match d'avant bobby fischer ii a
été gagné assez facilement donc pas
rouis fans finalement sans trop
sourciller parfois il ya aussi l'idée
kerry des quatre impôts sur cavale et
prend refaire ses prend alors ça donne
pas forcément l'avantagent mais ça
permet de jouer quelque chose de très
symétriques ça peut parfois être
intéressant surtout s'ils ont réussi à
mettre par la suite le pion des 5
mais après c'est pas c'est pas un cas de
figure forcément habituel il ya cette
idée de jouer gkf 4,5 aussi pour prendre
de l'espace al elle allait droit est ici
les noirs jouent petit rock donc un pied
qui se jette dans la gueule du loup et
par rapport au match que l'on avait
suivi en quarts de finale où un homme
qui avait battu goût nina on peut voir
qu'un pied un petit peu accéléré elle
joue elle joue plus rapidement elle se
développe
bien dans l'ouverture évidemment comme
elle le fait à chaque fois mais au lieu
de prendre une minute une minute trente
pour le faire elle a pris 30 secondes
donc elle a un petit peu accéléré un
jour un petit peu plus vite et ça
pourrait porter ses fruits ce qu'on se
rappelle contre valentina qu'elle avait
eu beaucoup de problèmes à ce niveau là
et qu'elle avait perdu quelques parties
à cause du manque de temps donc c'est un
problème et un défaut qui à laquelle
tente de corriger alors que je dis ça et
qu'elle réfléchisse 30 secondes pour un
coût mais ça paraît pas ça paraît pas
incroyable puisque vous prendre des
trois est un coup ici puisque sur ces
prend peut-être on fait juste cavalier e
5 sur des quatre ans de racailles et
prend est sûr qu'il prend au 5d prend
2,5
la situation de la structure paraît
complètement confortable pour les noirs
donc à la jouent tour à 8 de son côté
alès faire fou prend g4 de la part des
blancs fou prend des trois dames prend
des trois donc plutôt ne des doubles pas
les pions mais veut gagner du temps
évidemment sur l' attaque côté blanc et
carré lieu 5 n'est pas jouable à cause
de cavaliers prend pions prend et dame
prend 17 qui gagnerait la dame pour les
blancs grâce au cloud âge
donc après dame prend des trois peut
être un coup comme dame e6 est
envisageable pour attaquer le pion à
deux escales sont plus fortes que moi
alors en partie longue c'est sûr à dix
mille pour cent en partie rapide c'est
sûr à dix mille pour cent en blitz sur
internet j'ai un score positif contre
kosteniuk après énormément de partie
donc elle est peut-être un peu plus
forte que moi quand même mais ça doit
être quand même assez serré j'imagine
elle doit être un peu plus forte ou
moins donc ça dépend des cadences mais
elles sont très généralement plus forte
que moi est juste là sur ce truc
spécifique là l'écart est peut-être plus
réduit
donc
elles ont toutes le niveau j'ai ouais
tout non berli sandales ce dans ce
tournoi pas toutes les filles qu'on a
aujourd'hui oui je passais à
saint-quentin bon coup et c'est
discutable d'un côté ça affaiblit droit
mais de l'autre côté on veut ça on veut
s'activer donc à f/5 c'est un peu à
double tranchant là est ce que tu veux
pas jouer f4 par exemple pour prendre de
l'espace à fond ouais ça aurait pas
grand maître mais là lui manque
il lui manque une norme et six points
elo quoi quelque chose comme ça donc on
peut dire qu'elle a quasiment le niveau
gm après c'est pas gm de premier plan
cgem entre guillemets faible pour un gms
comprenons nous bien c'est pas c'est pas
gm comme mvl car le sel ou quoi ces
gènes deuxième femme à femme un peu plus
ouais non mais j'aime niveau fabray mais
par exemple cornetto ou maso c'est déjà
plus fort je pense encore que m puis à
la cam était très bien classé mais que
kosteniuk oui je pense pas que kosteniuk
été 2006 ans donc c'est quand même plus
fort et cornetto est maso même s'ils
sont très forts c'est pas des grands
maîtres de premier plan non plus cédé
très bon joueur quand on nettoie été
champion de france et c'est donc c'est
c'est du lourd
mais je veux dire que c'est pas baky
c'est pas mvl c'est pas joël lautier
s'est passé pavla tu sais quand même
bien en dessous qu'en 2000 simple quand
même non quand même pas l été 2006 en 25
ou 30 je pense même puis 26 rentrait
donc un pisse à être niveau de maso
l'écart est meilleur que maso bord non
ils doivent avoir un niveau similaire
sont un peu plus forts que fab mais ils
ont un niveau similaire dans des styles
complètement différents
way we fans elle a déjà un niveau très
bon grand maître metop j'aime j'ai du
mal à dire puisqu'elle a jamais été 2007
pour moi en fait top j'aime ça commence
à 2007 quoi dans mon esprit ou alors si
c'était un petit peu plus tôt quand tu
es rentré dans le top 30 top 40 mondial
donc c'est quand même pas non plus ce
niveau-là 2529 max alexandra ouais donc
alexandra ces gens au niveau de fab en
longue peut-être un peu plus fort
peut-être un peu moins forte mais c'est
c'est dans ces eaux là
si l échange la tourelle gagne un pion
alors non parce que y'a f2 en prise à la
fin j'imagine parce que si tu fais tout
reprend tout reprend dame prend adam
prend fou prend fou prend fou prend mais
il ya dame prend à deux quand même il ya
deux attaqués d'où le roi bien des 5 est
maintenant si tu prends tout il sait ça
c'est que j'ai paris et regarder au bond
au bon endroit et maintenant si tu
prends tout y est faiseur en l'air à la
fin
wen au niveau de femme actuelle c'est
quand même un gros niveau on est
d'accord mais c'est pas non plus
d'objets mois sans manquer de respect à
fab
c'est très bon joueur et ce qu'elles
peuvent se voir là car oui si elles ont
envie mais je pense pas qu'elle s'en
battent à garder la cam ouverte
bon y'a pas fou prend f4 à cause de jets
cinq mois la position envoya un pion
passé mais il est pas protégé il est
bloqué par la dame qui est pas un bon
bloqueur mais d'un autre côté dans cette
position elle peut pas être délogés
il ya ni foot case blanche ni cavaliers
et les noirs qui ont un agréable 4
contre 3 donc à mon avis ça doit plus ou
moins ce qu'ont pensé même si je
prendrai les blancs niveau top ligue 1
mais pas avec des champions au non
j'aurais pas dû top ligue 1 non plus
birdman s'en va c'est ses marques
j'aurais dit niveau ligue 1 fut genre
des clubs comme sainté justement comme
on parle football mais mais j'aurais dit
c'est quand même loin du niveau du psg
ou même de lyon même de marseille c'est
plutôt way niveau au niveau ligue 1 à
niveau au niveau bordeaux au niveau
synthé encore que peut-être pas quand
même peut-être un peu moins quand même
je sais pas
elle va gagner des seins qu'elle va la
gagner ce coquet frictional games des
cinq l'autre gagne f2 mais le pion est
tellement avancée retour f5 après 7
tours f5 avec id touré fut tout on prend
un f4 voilà il ya tour f5 pensée sur fou
aux sept tours tour des quatre f3 faut
prendre le staff de à oui ok c'est très
dangereux bien vous prendre cette ici
faut le voir sur tours 5 qui arrive 3ème
et la f3a ça se retourne elle pense
gagner la pièce mais surtout recettes
tour cette fausse est gf2 boisjoli
défense la 2a jolie défense la junkie
donc tout faire vous prendre ces
attaques de tous rêvent 5 tours 7 tours
f2 elle a bien défendu âme qui met
maintenant à ya le problème de connexion
à sa peugeot à la connexion ce match et
amis à voilà qui me rend heureux
le match qui se joue à la connexion
j'adore j'adore ça elle peut perdre à
l'aco c'est extraordinaire bah ils
furent eux à je suis très heureux là si
ça paiera la connexion c'est mon gros
bonheur vous me connaissez voilà ça doit
être égal 1 il ya deux pions passé de
chaque côté mais quand même des pions
passé des deux côtés avec les pions qui
envoie c'est ça peut se gagner pour
l'une ou l'autre la question c'est ce
que ces 3 h 5 qui on prend au tour prend
un pion prend roi h7
c'est marrant il ya un pion de plus mais
c'est les noirs qui prennent le pion qui
est plus proche et qui vont à dame
ça se peut être une faute qu'on peut
faire avec peu de temps elle fait
tourner qu'à 3 h 7 alors sur h5 elle
voulait échec
je voulais juste regardé la finale sur
h5 la rue tombé huit ans qu'elle fait ça
si on prend ces 6 ha oui c'est bien joué
roy g6 ses sept tours à schwyz et bien
la scala fait ouais elle l a très bien
joué lacoste éduquer tour des huit à
sémalens ton prend ag2 c8 berhouet mais
ça va aller où ces huit dames auraient
d'abord ça marchait dans les deux sens
et c'est gagné pour kosteniuk qui prend
qui prend le lead donc on a dit que
c'était hyper important pour un pic au
neruda
euh de dominer dans le 5 + 1 et aidant
le 3 + 1 dans un deuxième temps et pour
le moment c'est kosteniuk qui fait
l'écart et qui prend le premier point il
faudrait pas que la joueuse russe 120 là
dès le début du match parce que à mon
avis surtout qu nehru aujourd'hui à des
problèmes de connexion à la de gros
problèmes de connexion avec une barre
donc en bullet hell aura aucune chance
en gros faut à quel tournoi minimum à
plus savoir + 2 je pense que koné roux
est déjà en danger ainsi elle perd si
elle perd 3 0 le 5 + 1 je pense que le
match sur la quasi plié si elle le perd
2,1
il y aura déjà une énorme option pour
kosteniuk à l'aco du gange en sueur
c'est terrible c'est terrible on va voir
ce que ce que ça donne je vais me
remettre le timing histoire de la voir
voilà ce 17me jouit donc c'est juste que
je voulais me faire un avis il y aura
sûrement que trois parties dans le cinq
plus un on n'est pas parti pour un match
qui va extrêmement dur est donc d'accord
pas parti pour avoir un match qu'ils
aillent très très loin dans le dans le
temps donc cette partie du match récent
dossier qui était de ses recettes et pas
en baissant même et que c'est lui
qu'elle est toujours là un dame prend
des quatre qui a des seins qu'elle
s'accroche
fu c5 est ce que tour d un fou prend des
quatre cahiers bessin il va récupérer la
pièce normalement oui normalement oui
oui oui non sur un ouais je pense je
pense que les que les chances de goût
nina sont minces et je pense coucher
nina devrait bien dominé kosteniuk après
en finale je sais pas pourquoi je son
hochet nina plus stratégique et je pense
qu'elle devrait pouvoir faire assez mal
dans les ouvertures kosteniuk aussi qui
a l'habitude de jouer sur internet
barbarians emma a joué les arénas est de
jouer beaucoup et est du coup bas comme
je disais je sais pas je peux aller
regarder vous allez voir mon écran une
seconde mais jouer beaucoup de parties
contre elle bon
on s'est décalé oui j'ai est ce qu'on
voit à droite mon écran non je peux vous
montrer la joue vraiment beaucoup de
partis parce que contre moi on a à jouer
on a joué 40 partis ensemble avec
alexandra donc ça veut dire que c'est
une joueuse qui joue beaucoup sur
internet parce que pour arriver à 40
parties contre un simple et seul
adversaire c'est c'est énorme mais elle
joue en bullet hell un classement
correct en bits ça allait bien elle est
bien partout donc tout ça pour dire que
c'est une joue et ce qui est vraiment
habitué aux joutes sur internet et ça
forcément qu'on le veuille ou non c'est
un avantage des trucs d'échiquier 2d 3d
on en a déjà parlé du coup elle a plus
l'habitude est forcément
forcément ça paye c'est normal 25 23 23
16 pour moi ouais mais bon ça a pressé
c'est anecdotique
ça c'est anecdotique mais ça veut dire
qu'elle a l'habitude de jouer et qu'elle
joue beaucoup de partis est forcément
sûr qu'elle est bien en qu'elle a
l'habitude des matches longs qui a eu
l'habitude des arénas enfin voilà elle
et elle est très entraînés sur ce genre
de format est forcément sur des niveaux
resserré comme ça ça peut faire la diff
mais l'aco nehru domine largement la
partie allait serait bien connus ou
reviennent dans le match
quelque part goût nina est pas couché
nina a vraiment été la plus forte à mon
avis sur sur le truc et mérite
complètement de remporter cette
compétition goût ni n'a été pas mal mais
quand même elle a eu un match va
beaucoup de chance sur contre joue
auncun qui s'est vraiment joué sur la
connexion donc je sais pas je pense
kosteniuk mériterait plus when the title
tune aussi cadillac se mêlent joue
beaucoup sur internet alexandra les
vallées vraiment très entraînés sur
internet
l'exposition est dur j'ai l'impression
pour les noirs ya un pion de plus mais a
tellement tous les visas vis pourri pour
les noirs est tellement d'activités pour
les blancs alors qu'elle prend b cette
dame premier set 5 once kaka et des cinq
qui bloque la diagonale du fou
donc il faut trouver mieux
c'est ce que doit chercher conejo
mais c'est pas facile de trouver un gain
est ce que tu penses que le fait qu'on
finisse par jouer plus sur internet avec
des cadences rapides change les
ouvertures et façon de jouer oui
forcément ça joue plus pratique sur en
cadence rapide soit sur internet ou pas
et on peut avoir un éventail de
d'ouverture plus important et on peut
jouer des choses un peu moins forte pour
une partie pour piéger ou pour embêter
ouais il sacrifie le fou en baie de hors
jeu voit pas trop comment de sacrifier
je peux les changer mais je vois pas
l'intérêt c'est comme une belle pièce la
g4g mien elle veut faire un g5 qui a
rallié prend et e5 pour commencer à
toute attaque est mal a causé nuke en
légère difficulté un qui est rangé
quatre élevages est d'alger 3 j'imagine
et ça va commencer à vraiment attaquer
partout
l'âge venant ciapa kébé cette dame des
sept tours 17
je veux apprendre du cavalier yamaha
tanger s'est tu prends de la dame est
fou prend 1,6 g si ces dames g5 et ça
m'a l'air de terminer la partie
je pense que connaît où va le voir elle
fait qu'il y prend bessette d'ailleurs à
la resquille ailleurs dame prend dame g3
joue la pièce de moins mais la tour
prend 17 essais games c'était sûr
qu'elle verrait fou prend f6 g6 dame g5
et le problème c'est que c'est même pas
le matériel c'est qu'on a du mal à
défendre ses cases noires d'alger 5
c'est le coup j'ai dit tempo mais adam
f4 d'un match 4 mg 5 dames e3 tout ça ça
a l'air d'être le même règne du jeu
c'est pas d'âme g5 ça semble être le
plus direct
on va regarder alors dit et ce qui est
un problème avec un coup comme dames 3
leurs dix proposent eux cinq du coût
d'un mach 6 ha oui mais ça est ridicule
stands et william hague directement
assez incroyable alors d'yvois fois je
crois il voit pas d'âme h6 je vois pas
du tout comment défendre après dame g5
elle abandonne mais je crois que dame 3
d'un f4 dame g5 fait tous les coups
mené au match j'ai l'impression et ça
fait un partout on pique une nouvelle
fois un fait mal non mais leur dit si
terrible y proposait fois trop près
proposait pas damage si tu fais maths en
2d fois lors d'issue donc vu que cette
partie a été rapide si cette partie dure
pas trop il pourrait y avoir quatre
parties en 5 + 1 on va voir
en tout cas un pic il ya vraiment dominé
de la tête et des épaules en cette
deuxième partie il va falloir c'était
7,7 ouest indienne là je vous remonte
rapidement mais là vraiment on est
rapidement dominé un la dame s'est
retrouvée sans case et du coup bon là on
a la même position que dans la partie
numéro 1 exactement g4 fou prend des
trois dames prend des trois ça va
continuer comme ça apparemment ça avait
convenu aux deux joueuses
il y avait un plan avec roy je suis des
f-5 quoi elle fais 5 enfin bref cinq
voiliers d'amd 5,3 à schwyz
elle rejoue la même chose et puis on va
voir si ça lui donne de meilleurs
résultats
dans des 5 3 h suite on répète la partie
précédente
donc gunino qui doivent se regarder le
match en ce moment-même grande
supportrice de supportrices donne
piccone roux supporte soif je craque
la supportrice pour tenter d'aller enfin
pour aller en finale elle a besoin d'une
victoire de m p sinon c'est kosteniuk
qui ira donc très haut noirs ici est-ce
qu'elle va rejouer le plan avec f4 de
tout à l'heure pour bien fermer les
lignes
fg âge et ça paraissait bizarre ça
ouvrait la colonne âge donc elle ferme
avec f 4 mai fu des deux spéciales
laquelle philippe weppe 6 vous prend f4f
ou prend ces trois ce genre de choses
mais ça semble plus agréable à jouer
pour les blancs la connexion d'un outil
qui est bien revenu c'est une autre
bonne nouvelle et on va avoir le droit à
un match très serré les amis à mon avis
entre les deux femmes est ce que la tour
va partir vers eux deux mais voilà
peut-être ce tour g27 un coude dame si
si si pour provoquer les échanges la
même si c'est le coup que je regarderai
vraiment dame prend tout reprend tourin
par exemple les way se turent f4s
peut-être un petit peu en danger
je voulais faire tourner 8 mai il ya fou
prend f4 bon il va falloir jouer un truc
comme ça
est-ce pas forcément agréable agréable
c'est pas forcément agréable agréable
non plus trois minutes pour un pays
qui joue dames 6
elle va échanger en hausse 6 sur rien on
peut échanger et toi à récupérer h4 est
possible il ya peut-être ray le truc
c'est que pure f4 reste mais là
peut-être cavaliers ou 5 fait un truc
c'est que tours 1-1 peut-être tour huit
tours prend tout reprend fou prend un f4
peut-être tour f 6 tours 1 a et
peut-être la rente aller plus loin roy
g8 tour huit tours 4 et non des cinq ça
peu vrai peut-être y avait ce truc là
mais ce pion f4 de toute façon il va
rester faible pendant longtemps mais
j'ai peut-être raté cette enfilade
mais dans tous les cas le plus bref 4 va
rester faible
ça va être compliqué
tours 8 jouer je me demande si ça va
échanger et faire tout re pense appris
ici à et surtout reprend il ya cavaliers
prend c'est ça le truc c'est tout
reprend cavaliers prend maintenant
ah oui non c'est horrible pour mpi ce
qui a pu le tour f 8 ème 1 et se prend
cavaliers detroit et f3 ça va être
terrible
j'arrive personnes ont même pu apprécier
cette finale pourquoi ça me russe trop
long le tournoi vous prendrez cinq pions
pranger 5e 3 et ça va tout protéger
après je dirais c'est peut-être dire que
tu es sain d'esprit si tu arrives pas
apprécié un truc aussi l'ont peut-être
du positif parfait retour f1 et sur
quelle cinq épreuves cinq prises 5 3d de
ouais ok ça va aller pour pour un petit
pour que causé new pardon et pas du tout
pour une pile en plus elle peut pas
échanger les tours la finale de pions va
être complètement perdante
ouais ok elle peut ok roi des rois f2
s'arrête jouer c'est sûr qu'elle va pas
à quoi qu'elle peut faire sa c4 détroit
ces trois rois c2 et enchaîner
j'imagine qu'il y ait trois coupes du
monde avec les mêmes équipes genre une
coupe du monde avec l'inde le salvador
la slovaquie le gabon et le vietnam et
qu'on leur fasse trois fois d'affilée
bas quatre fois d'affilée plus tôt ah
bah oui mais oui à un moment donné ça
pue trop d'intérêts oui comment on sait
que la finale de pions et perdantes b
winner alors ça c'est une bonne question
merci de me l'avoir posée on sait pas ce
que quasiment toutes les finales de
pions avec un pion - sont perdantes donc
là tu te dis qu'avec les blancs bon on
va pas faire re 5 exprès pour faciliter
mais qui va réussir à faire ça tu vas
réussir à faire ça a bloqué on va dire à
admettre comme ça on va dire qu'on va on
va partir du principe tu vas réussir à
faire ça avec les blancs et qu'à un
moment donné tu vas partir de l'autre
côté tu vas raser tous les pions parce
que tu seras premier est donc en gros on
part du principe que tu vas réussir à
obtenir cette position si tu échanges et
donc que ça doit être perdant j'ai pas
de pourcentage mais c'est vrai à mon
avis dans 95 % des cas
jeff toobin f k 3g 5 ha ont regardé il
ya un souci tours fc 3 pranger 4g c'est
3 prend h5 et la tour c 5 couvre tout
et il semble pas ok tu as tenté roi des
deux rois des 3a 3b 4 pour essayer de
prendre l'aventage le roi est quand même
complètement coupé la tour tu vas partir
en g2 j'imagine et on va essayer de de
monter le roi est de chasser cette tour
ok tour 17 ça me paraît bizarre mais la
ducale clairoix g62 trucks qu à trois
rois ces trois b 4 à bab tour c6 des
cinq tours c5 et on réussit pas à
bloquer la tour donc là le scénario c3
c6 aura droit des rois et 6 et 3 e 6 il
ya b5 aussi qui est intéressant c'est
pour ça qu'elle a réfléchi
bon les blancs sont toujours en train de
presser mais mais je crois que b5 fait
nul tout de suite en vrai je crois qu b5
annule tout de suite parce que tu va
échanger les pions et tu vas faire
brasser 3 et 6 3 des 6 wiki est un autre
problème qu'on n'avait pas vu vrai
conejo qui est plus fort dans le jeu
vraiment après je pense qu'elle va
souffrir en bullet hell va souffrir en
manque de temps mais je pense que
l abbé cbc je la trouve plus fort dans
le jeu les amis voilà ça devrait faire
nul je vous dirai ce qui va encore y
avoir une partie à la faim ou pas
puisque là il n'y a aucun plan de guerre
ni pour l'une ni pour l'autre donc ce
qui est intéressant c'est de voir
combien de temps il reste une vingtaine
de secondes dans la cadence même un peu
moins donc là si la partie dure encore
quelques coups ce sera la dernière
voilà vraiment aucun moyen de gagner
pour l'aïe a juste rien à faire ça va
faire nul et je sais pas s'ils restent
encore non il reste plus de temps ça
s'est joué à deux trois secondes près là
ça s'est joué à deux trois secondes près
mais il ya plus de temps dans la cadence
ça favorise plutôt alexandra je dirais
de d'avoir moins de parti et donc le
score est de 1-1 et demi un an et demi
après cette phase 2 5 + 1 on se retrouve
dans deux petits type dans trois petites
non cinq petites minutes je vais y
arriver ces cinq minutes la pause pour
la prochaine cadence pour 30 minutes de
trois plus un je vous dis à tout de
suite tout le monde en vous passant en
vo repassant en attendant la dernière
partie en entier qui a été dominée quand
même par alexandra mai mais un petit
bonne technique en finale qui a réussi à
annuler at feat tout le monde
m
alors les mecs les jouets ce qu'ils sont
en train de revenir et il nous reste
encore 45 minutes de compétition les
amis pour savoir qui de alexandra
kosteniuk ou valentine agout nina ira en
finale donc on va voilà donc palpitant à
cette finale avec un énorme enjeu
évidemment savoir qui jouera la finale
du speech est féminin la grande finale
après ses quatre grands prix quatre
semaines de compétition et donc la
finale je crois qui a lieu normalement
demain mais j'ai pas j'ai pas eu
confirmation de la date bizarrement mais
c'était écrit c'était écrit avec c'était
c'était lundi pour lever je vais
demander d'ailleurs je pense c'est lundi
que c'est demain 14 heures
normalement donc je vais demander
confirmation parce qu'il ya pas eu de
même sur les articles j'ai pas su pas
réussi à trouver vraiment leur temps
permet donc c'est demain je demandais à
la même heure
on va voir c'est peut-être 15 heures ok
c'est trente trente à trente minutes
plus tard donc demain lundi 15 heures ce
sera la grande finale
on attend que les parties reprennent là
pour ses 38 à venir
quand j'écris un petit message aux
femmes aussi
et donc on va repartir
donc ces petits c 4
cavalia et 6e 4e 3e 6b trois des cinq
donc ces petits genre dans gleize avec
franchetto avec double option qui est au
même ça peut être intéressant pour les
blancs ça une des parties stratégiques
au long cours qui sont pas pas toujours
simple à simple à jouer trois et parfois
on peut jouer avec des quatre situe à
ressembler à un système cole ou parfois
on peut retarder le coup des cats et je
vais juste fou de rock et le joue un
petit peu plus tard donc là il ya
beaucoup de possibilités pour les blancs
peut prendre du plomb pour jouer un pion
isolés on peut prendre du cavalier pour
ne pas le faire sur isolé puisque après
des cats généralement les pions à c et d
vont disparaître
alors qu'est ce qui va être joué
maintenant ce que ça va être des cadres
donc maintenant peut-être foule de
d'abord fou b5 puis rock puis des quatre
meco des roues qui prend trop de temps
c'est toujours la même chose sûre qu'en
partie longue elle était beaucoup plus
forte que kosteniuk arrêté 26 30
c'est quand même un gros gros classement
26 30
mais après c'est peut-être pas une
liseuse dans l'âme et on sent parfois
qu'elle prend un peu trop de temps pour
certains coûts même si je crois qu'elles
ont aussi deux leaders des grands prix
fidh féminin pour pour une qualification
aux candidats ou je ne sais quoi
donc c'est vraiment une grosse joueuses
inconnus ou après c'est pas forcément le
format comme je vous dis qui qui
l'avantagent le plus donc elle joue des
quatre ici l'idée c'est de jouer contre
un pion isolé éventuellement en d5
cavalier e 4 est ici des français 5
peut-être
prise prise d'état de kaïs ces trois
prises et d'échanger du matériel qui est
france et roi fou prend ses 3000 y aura
le fou qui vient de ranger 4 ça doit
plus ou moins aller un pour les noirs
même si à ce point isolé
on va avoir un ce qu'elle décide de
faire je vous rappelle un 30 minutes à
jouer dans ce dance 3 plus un cavalier
bd d'accord donc elle s'en prend au
carré lieu 4 et elle veut elle veut
peut-être sûr qu'il y prend reprendre de
la dame pour pas avoir le visa vie mais
du coup à l'attaqué pas le pion des cinq
arrêts ce qu'on peut faire [ __ ] ans et
six pions français si ce qu'éprouve
capture on prend 1,4 dame prend des huit
tours quand des 8es un coup de cavaliers
en d4 je peux vous montrer ce genre de
choses peut être une idée je serais
parti pour ça et genre sur fou prend des
cats juste pour montrer vous prendrez
katia foot couleurs opposées mais y'a le
pion ces six ans pour faire un tour
c'est un tour ses cinq tours c'est un
tour à cinq tours à 6 et visait les deux
pions bon elle part pour ça j'ai
l'impression
alors elle laisse car elle y prend des
huit ici avec cet ordre de coûts c'est
quand même dommage un blessé qui prend
des 8
elle aurait pu commencer par france et 6
pour pas laisser cette option à son
adversaire
c'est dommage je pense faut faire qu'il
prend des 8 6 il y aura quand même
avantage blanc pour remettre la tour
enfin le cavalier bouge une tour en c1
et jouer la colonne c'est tout cas koné
rookie une nouvelle fois dans le milieu
de jeu est plus forte mais elle se met
mal autant ouais donc ça rentre comme
dans cette position finalement elle mais
le camion du sein car moi je vais
montrer qu'il prend cahier des quatre
pour vous montrer un truc pédagogique
mais cave a lieu cinq attaques le fou
attaque le pion c'est encore mieux un
prêt ça laisse des tours d2 mais je vais
une surchauffe ça qu'elle commencera par
tour des 1
donc là plus personne qui parle sur le
chat ou c'est moi qui ai plus les
messages ce possible que tout le monde
soit à barrer dommage quand meme pour
cette fin de cette fin de tournoi après
je vous comprends aussi sykes et ça fait
longtemps que ça dure il fait beau on
est dimanche
tout le monde admire air pur et faisait
1 s'est calmée mais je comprends aussi
un état des quatre ans et six qui vont
rodez moi j'aurais commencé par tours fc
un jeu page aurait pas eu envie de
laisser tourner de direct aurait
peut-être pris mon temps pour prendre ce
pion mais l'ondé juste fou des cats
échanges les futures mais le cahier en
déca tu va échanger une tour fous ces
trois attaques attaque la tour
autour des 3 et être fou b4 café tour
ces deux tours fc a probablement en
échange à tour d un tour des huit tours
tour d un tour s'est vite tour des huit
pardon qui est possible alors les coûts
marrant il ya foule et de aussi prise
prisé à mince enfermement de cavaliers
avec la focale hausse est bien joué ça
de la part de kosteniuk lecavalier qui
va se faire ramasser
oh là là le piège très très bien joué de
la part d'alexandre à qu'il y avait une
mauvaise position une nouvelle fois mais
qui a qui gagnent sur un pillage on sait
qu'elle est forte en pillages un
kosteniuk elles tendent et petit piège
pas forcément facile à voir et koné ou
qui se fait prendre on sent plus forte
un stratégiquement nettement même et en
blitz et d'autres d'autres qualités qui
sont importantes
la vitesse pour voir les petites
tactiques c'est vraiment important et la
qos et new qui a trouvé ce piège assez
sympa qui lui permet de remporter la
partie est de reprendre un point
d'avancé il va falloir faire attention
pour koné rouyn faut pas qu'elles
qu'elles commencent à arriver à - 2 - 3
parce qu'après normalement bull est allé
moins forte et ça va ça va être
compliqué mais c'était joli la petite
focale aller il lui reste encore à mon
avis trois parties dance 3 + 1 pour pour
revenir à la marque et pourquoi pas même
prendre l'aventage donc là les noirs ont
pris eux le centre avec les pions 5 et
d5 et les blancs vont attaquer ce centre
avec les fous à b3 et g3 on voit souvent
à ce genre de scénario échec avec un
joueur qui prend le centre et l'autre
qui l'attaquent h6 à éviter car les g5
plutôt logique car elles étaient deux
on va faire quoi il va faire fou j'ai
trois dames f3 tour de tours quelque
chose comme ça tamira fou g4 c'est long
ça à préparer en prévision des
équilibres femme déséquilibrée position
équilibrée en termes de chance mais
déséquilibré en terme de ce qu'on a on a
vraiment le centre contre l'attack du
centre et c'est pas facile de jouer avec
les noix on a soupé 8la qui est mal
placée par rapport aux cavaliers bessin
qui fait un énorme taf
koné roux qui a déjà eu une minute de
retard sur causé nyuki il me semble que
la joueuse russe fait l'écart 1 ici les
a mis dans ce match semble qu'elle
commence à dominer la partie précédente
fait mal
une partie où elle était derrière et où
elle réussit à à l'emporter et l'a de
nouveau elle continue à jouer très vite
à la haye l'a vraiment ajuster son sa
vitesse de jeu là par rapport à conejo
elle essaye de tout envoyer tempo et je
crois que qu'alexandra en train de
construire sa victoire après il peut y
avoir des faits de jeu qui renverse la
pression mais là il semble vraiment que
c'est elle qui commença à faire la
différence
on sent vraiment la dynamique du match
qui est en train de de tourner en faveur
de la joueuse russe
une victoire dans cette partie ferait
vraiment très très mal à la tête de koné
roues avec deux points de retard ça
pourrait commencer à être extrêmement
compliqué pour pour la joueuse indienne
allégé 5 fu g3 ça va être jouée tempo ll
se prend tous les coups tempo koné
rookie eux qui a nettement accéléré
consignes ou qui fait qui fait très mal
elle fait elle fait vraiment mal à une
deux minutes de retard maintenant pour
koné roux qui est en train de qui en
train de sombrer elle à 1 face aux coups
de butoir de la joueuse russe comme je
vous dis hein c'est pas vraiment une
question de cette partie 2 qui va la
gagner c'est plus c'est plus une
question de dynamique de match on l'a vu
dans la première partie il a déjà avec
cette petite arnaque y est tombé koné
roux qui s'était mis trop mal autant et
qui a perdu à cause de ça et on sent que
que chess queen veut frapper là où ça
fait mal là où ça fait très mal dans
l'est dans les premiers lacets de
l'ascension déjà causé new qui accélère
et impie qui il ya vraiment du mal à
suivre le rythme plus que 28 secondes
déjà pour la joueuse indienne qui
continue 1 malgré le manque de temps à
perdre secondes / seconde à elle va
mettre plus de dix secondes à jouer ce
coup ouais c'est terrible c'est terrible
elle va elle va encore claqué beaucoup
de temps pour faire des prend ces quatre
là il va y avoir peut-être cavaliers
prend pour rejaillir vers des six est
attaqué la tour peut-être qu'à ibb et
des six pour attaquer la tour et le pion
aux cavaliers c'est pour attaquer aussi
à vii d'ailleurs écho nehru qui
souffrent l'a vraiment très clairement
cavale et ses cd 6 et 1 et un coup ici
et avec peut-être même du damas deux
pour enchaîner causé new qui cherchent
déjà le killer blot la moitié des 6,6
avait tout reprend des six pardon je
dédie une petite bêtise telle idée dame
b 8 mai mais peut-être un an cavaliers 3
du coût pour attaquer le fou g4 s'en
prendre aux pions sur fouet 6 peut-être
des cinq des six puis cavaliers c7 et là
ça commence à faire à faire très mal il
ya peut-être de la case f5 aussi qui
peut s'illuminer via un coup comme food
et un pour proposer les changes de fous
où elle fait des cinq plus que 5
secondes 1 pour reconnaître ou des cinq
des six envoyés koné rookie place
l'accélération maintenant plus de cinq
secondes pour la joueuse indienne mais
normalement 5 secondes avec plus de
seconde à la pendule ça peut encore se
ferme avec +1 c'est très compliqué
cependant la joueuse indienne qui a
trouvé peut-être dû cavaliers detroit
pour pour s'en prendre aux pièces
blanches et couper un les colonnes
cavaliers des cinq jouer plus que trois
secondes à l'esa échanges
koné rookie réussi à faire f 5
alors là et scary voir un fou aux six
pour chasser la tour les coûts là qui
pourraient s'enchaîner tour sert ya
toujours qu'il y ait des trois pénible
peut-être fou au 6e tour des huit à elle
prend des six prises des 6 reprises des
six
donc elle joue quelque chose de pratique
on peut peut-être faire tour assez
inquiets des trois tours ces huit noms
elle fait pousser 4 plus tranquille
damas est elle va tenter tour des deux
co nehru et c'est dommage que les noirs
ont maintenant une position plus ou
moins correct mais malheureusement il ya
plus de temps quoi s'inquiéter bien joué
dames b2 dam des quatre safer dame prend
des quatre tours prend des quatre avant
qu'elle ne joue dame ces deux pour
tourner un gardé à garder les dames sur
l'échiquier non l échange vu le manque
de temps d'amasser 2 était peut-être pas
si idiot puisque le temps prend des cas
de pré move était est et certains
auraient permis de re grappiller un peu
de temps cependant ouais elle a elle
fini par faire une erreur tactique tout
re d1 et c'en est fini des chances de
koné ou dans cette partie qui maintenant
à deux points de retard
elle fait elle fait grise mine à la
joueuse indienne
attendons un peu la recadrer est la lcl
s'est perdu sur le bas de l'écran
non c'est le costume qui est petit qui
aime mal cadrées elles et puis koné
rouelle qui s'était perdu en bas d'écran
mais elle est en grande grande
difficulté attendez ça je connais pas du
tout l'enquêté prend b5 à lequel prend
1,4 pardon et donc va faire un départage
donc le dernier match sera pas un départ
ailleurs un départage ou nina gauche et
nina non je vois pas qui les départagera
un body now she nina je crois que vous
chez nina un meilleur des partages je
crois que chez nina un meilleur des
partages et il ira ira donc en finale
alors
on va voir kébé 4
jouer
donc à 3
ok qui revient en c3 et prend un très
bref 33 alors ça à partir en dame
d'amiens dame g3 peut-être pour attaquer
le pion à le pion g7
donc
ça va partir comme ça
alors d'amr à jouer alors on va voir
comment est-ce que ça va ça va continuer
à attaquer à l'est le roi empty mais il
me semble que kosteniuk soit toujours
bien les gars comme en attaque et g7
après c'est un peu peut-être car l ie 4k
relief 6 mais ça devient dur parce que
ou cavale et g5
mais le truc c'est que le fou bessette
contrôle
et les bars dames c'est cette dame c6
peut-être la joie f5
puis on prend un f6 vous prend 1,6
alors vous pensez 4è pour les blancs a
une nouvelle fois élus ont aussi sans
difficulté je sais pas trop comment
s'est passée la non ce jeu commet pas
trop j'ai pas trop compris en fait la
série de coups de kosteniuk la s'éprend
et f5 voient leur père son pion je
mentirais pas pu et différemment on peut
importe c'est que le truc c'est qu'elle
repère le pion aussi ça n'a pas dû voir
le dame prend aussi ses échecs dames
france et 4 vient et du coup elle se
retrouve avec un pion de moins avec les
noirs mais elle réussit quand même à
contre-attaquer b2 et des cadors que
conejo est encore mal autant en 26
secondes ça peut suffire ici vu
l'avantagent cas là mais à mon avis
à mon avis ça devrait mal se passer pour
elle même prend avec quatre prises des 4
tours à des huit tours 17 tous rêvent dé
8 et le pion des quatre quais ou fou
prend ses 3es mais ça fait deux pions de
plus maintenant c'est fait je pensais
quand on a vu qu'un mais y en a deux des
pions de plus pas n'en connais roue peut
la gagner là quand même deux pions plus
c'est beaucoup mais quand mes écrits
pacotille qui a fait un truc très
bizarre là le cd edf 5 c'était c'était
vraiment soupçonnant elle a joué assez
vite en plus basse à la raison de jouer
vite elle veut mettre la pression à la
pendule mais là elle a juste filet du
matériel gratuitement
on va voir si elle peut sauver quelque
chose alors là attention de pas faire
trois premiers fous pranger 2 elle va
mettre la tour ans et 8 j'imagine tour
c'est un époux c4 je pense c'est le plan
alors ces cas soient sur foot français
kathakali français quatre tours france
et quatre tours f8 mate mc du couloir
par ah non on revient sur le direct fou
aussi ses 5,3 g 8 tours ici roi ses sept
tours à 6 où ils vont la connais ou qui
montre une grosse technique un jeu
vraiment très bien
le roi qui essayent de venir colmatée on
s'est tendu les amis recettes
le truc c'est qu'avec les noirs les
blancs là tu peux pas te faire piéger
continue qu'il veut jouer vite
vous êtes tour 17 pour tenter quelque
chose
trois des quatre fous g2 et / ou ac 4u
f1 genre de piège qui peut fonctionner
quand ton adversaire a peu de temps elle
a fait g6 des fous j'ai deux tu dois qui
a espéré roi ses quatre tours bessette
c'est pour ça que j'aurais fait tourner
cet avant en vrai l album si tomber
cette ces six tours prend b5 ses sept
tours dé 5,3 c4
et il ya la dame est imparable j'ai
l'impression je calcule tous à la main
sans ordi mais ce qu'elle va réussir à
la gagner kosteniuk fait ce qu'elle fait
c'est bien elle s'est mise mal et
maintenant elle elle prend son temps
tata ces cas-là deux chances de gagner
la partie tu peux la gagner en jouant
vite au début et en ayant une position
correcte du bhoutan adversaire est juste
mal autant est à gagner
et tu peux encore gagner sur des
connexions ou sur lenteur à la souris de
ton adversaire est sûre piège
donc en fait c'est comme si elle avait
deux shot de gains à chaque fois les
fouets fin elle ne menace pas vraiment
de prendre ici malheureusement mais elle
fait à six affaires fou j'ai deux je
pense à fait fou prend ainsi je pense
fou j'ai deux étaient plus précis
elle aurait pu l s'emmêler les pinceaux
là elle a très bien joué une longue
séquence mais maintenant qu nehru est
assez bien autant ça devrait perdre ça
sans trop de difficulté kosteniuk eux
qui a plutôt bien joué mais qui aurait
pu arnaquer son adversaire il ya un
moment donné elle aurait pu accélérer
quand elle avait plus qu'une seconde set
et je pense qu'elle aurait fait tomber
mais là pas trouvés les coûts ego néo
qui relance un peu l'intérêt du match
plus que plus qu'un point d'écart de
nouveau
il ya eu cavalli a insisté ces trois
crises et 6
d'accord ça repart dans ses ouvertures
qui a gagné entre ou et sarah tout à
l'heure où assez facilement donc ça va
pas renoncer dans ces italiennes thierry
4 4 cavaliers tirer viennoise hybride ça
assez insipide mais mais savent qu'il ya
du jeu en milieu def agir insipide
c'était c'est y pas de prendre
l'aventage ou de faire mal dans
l'ouverture quoi tu essayes dans un
deuxième point un deuxième temps par don
de faire souffrir
cavalia 5-fu b3 et va y avoir peut-être
du fou g4 qui va arriver à 6 pour le
moment elle peut vouloir jouer avec g5
g4 aussi cogné a pas dit son dernier mot
je pense qu'elle est on sent vraiment
qu'elle est plus forte que ses
adversaires je veux dire aux échecs pure
en compréhension et sert elle est quand
même beaucoup plus forte qu'au niveau
puisqu'elle avait déjà bien dominé goût
nina là je trouve qu'elle domine quand
même un petit peu
alexandra mais alexandra qui joue avec
de vraies convictions alain al'inverse
un peu de goût nina alexandra elle prend
vraiment le elle a vraiment une
stratégie de match un jeu joue vite bas
elle continue à faire ça je mets la
pression et je tends des petites des
petites toiles d'araignée et j'essaye
d'attraper ma proie un moment donné donc
elle défend le pion aux quatre
maintenant que le roi rockets et elle
menace puis on prend qui on prend et qui
apprend aux cinq sens pour ça à tour eu
8 il peut y avoir prise prise prise
prises et tu peux dire que 5 est en
prise que si tu prend 1,4 pour jouer
pour surtout reprend autour des 1 il ya
fou prend et statte échec mais du coup
tu peux peut-être ici prendre prendre et
prendre et ça ça va être complètement
égal ses traits symétriques et ça va
être complètement égal donc tu peux
jouer tour 8 ici avec les noirs avec
l'idée de d'attaqué ou quatre bons fous
g4 est tout à fait jouable aussi les
deux coups étaient bons voilà qu nehru
qui est beaucoup plus forte en longues
oui mais c'est plus une joueuse de l'umq
une joueuse de blitz donc c'est une
vraie est une vraie opposition de style
dans ce match marvel x vraiment que koné
rouges reviennent au score à mon avis
avant les bullet time propose des fous
proche si c'est pas possible assure fou
proche si je pense qu'ils auraient eu
cavaliers français 3 et du cou avait
toujours eu à égalité matérielle mais
ces genres de variantes jouable 1 c je
vous demande pas forcément mais c'est
pas forcément de regarder alors dit de
calculer on essaye de voir les options
des joueuses après il peut y avoir à
certains moments des toiles d'araignées
mais je pense tout ce qui est français 3
ça ça présentait pas de problème ou
cavaliers pros f2 peut-être et sur un
fou g7 et les 3 monts peu importe on va
pas se perdre dans cette variante d'armé
c'est de jouer et puis on prend tour 8
peut-être ou même le tour en huit plutôt
qu à f 7 est bien protégé qui peut
arriver à
ok cette fermeture là ça va peut-être
permettre imbéciles qui est bessette qui
a laissé cinq est je pense une nouvelle
fois que les cavaliers vont dominer les
fous mais jeudi une nouvelle fois dans
le sens où une nouvelle fois il semble
que koné roux prennent davantage dans le
petit jeu stratégique avait trempé 3
bizarre par contre parce que c'est le
mot est fou et tu vas pouvoir faire cb
est heureux à bab intéressant aussi
ah oui c'est très intéressant maintenant
c'est 4 b 4 c 5 et la colonne a été
ouverte est donc là c'est plutôt
kosteniuk qui domine finalement qui est
prend b3 très très bizarre
elle a remis en place la structure
adverse bon et même si avec a5b si ça va
être solide mais il peut y avoir des
percées à base de ces cartes food et de
c3 bekkat ce genre de choses peuvent
être possibles pense à toi allez quand
même pour les noirs mais ça paraissait
intéressant d'essayer jouer contre le
four b3 enfermés mais elle a décidé de
s'en débarrasser mais non seulement
kosteniuk a réussi à se débarrasser
d'une mauvaise pièce mais en plus elle
ramène un pion vers le centre elle
s'ouvre une colonne cependant le pion à
5 bien placé sur b4 et à des a4 aussi à
surveiller
on va voir les temps qu'elle met ce
cette structure en option en place b4
elle assure un katy d'avoir des dames b5
donc ça échange une fois mais on voit
que les blancs maintenant s'ils font c4
c5 ils ont une rupture claire et nette
ouais donc l'avantagé tôt blanc ici et
le temps pour conejo aussi difficile la
joueuse indienne en difficulté là il va
en voir f3m l'indre le pion la dame en
c6 monstrueuse qui attaquent la torah 8
écossais mieux qu'ils devraient pouvoir
refaire le break ici les amis on va voir
ça en tout cas elle réfléchit de nouveau
la joueuse russe c4 jouer cavalier 8 ou
calle g8 intéressant elle veut cavalier
e set pour chasser cette dame peut être
échangé le long de la colonne à remettre
une tour en a huit
ça peut être une vraie idée connais
aucun cas une bonne pointe de vitesse un
finalement juste à le semer trop mal
autant on essayant d'être trop principal
alors ça c'est point ces points un peu
tif mais aussi ses points négatifs de
jouer comme ça et là c'est kg 6 tours b
deux dames h 4 ça peut ça peut tourner
alors d'essai c'est un coup j'aurais
jamais joué parce que je trouve que ça
affaiblit largement ses 7es joie pape
qu'on s'est pas laissée échanges et nous
met dans tous les cas d'alger cinq
cavaliers f4 c'est hyper dur à jouer en
blitz a pour les blancs
la convergence des pièces noires sur le
roi est simple à jouer et elle s'est
mise en difficulté alors là est-ce qu'on
peut tenter un cavalier h4 mais il va y
avoir droit h1 je voulais tenter tour b3
pour essayer de me mettre une pression
assez tour ces trois peut-être dame de
aussi un coup les dames deux tours b 3-1
pareil pour attaquer le pion à f3
peut-être un tour b3 ici elle fait
tomber cette voie il détourné 3 les
doubles 1 c2 d'empêcher j'ai trois en
attaquant sa et de fer tour ces trois
pour dévier la dame et matin à angers 2
ça paraissait juste un coup extrêmement
logique donc auquel l'a pas fait mais
elle continue à mettre la pression plus
de deux secondes a partout pour par
contre pour koné roues elle envoie le
curage trois missions et emprises
d'accord être chaud qu'avec le temps
fait elle a joué la lafa h3c 6 ha mais
attention dame croit f3 à oui il y avait
de l'idée dans l'air quand même tour
c'est un était une erreur les amis ou là
ça devient chaud cavaliers f4 damage
cinq matches aux terribles
oh c'est terrible au kosteniuk qui se
fait mater en deux mots c'est elle qui
était bien au temps et qu'il réussit pas
à conclure
koné rookie lui mais la petite pointe de
vitesse etc o senio qui se prend le
maton deux ans elle est un petit peu
naïve 1 dans ce match là alexandra soit
soit faut partir pour accélérer
accélérer mais j'ai l'impression qu'elle
quel coin c'est un petit peu et conejo
réussi avec très peu de temps à s'en
sortir un chrono est vraiment au dessus
un an ce match on verra ce que ça donne
en bullet il reste combien de temps il
ya eu déjà quatre partis dans cette
cadence ça doit être ça doit être la
dernière et on va vivre une belle
session de deux bulles est il reste quoi
il reste 45 secondes doigts et joli
match donc dernière partie de 3 + 1 et
après il y aura le bullet alexandra qui
tremble un petit peu près en fin de
partie
ma favorite pour les usa restent
alexandra mai mais koné roux qui a
réussi à renverser le match un coup
alexandra qui avait une stratégie de
match qui marchait très bien
mais koné roux qui a réussi à lui
répondre dans deux parties avec peu de
temps et ça c'est assez étonnant on
l'attendait pas dans ce registre là
impie et finalement elle a elle fait mal
là on l'attendait pas qu'au seuil ou qui
semblait avoir trouvé là la stratégie
rêvée pour gagner ce match et finalement
et finalement une pile lui a répondu m
puis lui a répondu
de fort belle manière
donc ça a continué elle a fait à six
est-ce qu'avoir cavaliers des deux tours
c'est un peu fou b1
on va voir elle a fait à trois le têt
faire des cd4 pour chasser le fou
prendre de l'espace aller cogner rookie
en plus et mieux autant dans celle là
moi j'aimerais bien avoir une victoire
de m qui ici pour avoir un suspense
total dans les bulles est contre
greenhalgh avait été bien dominé puis
finalement elle avait réussi à l'arnaqué
contre contre le cours du jeu en bullet
verra ce que ça donne mais elle doit
quand même être en dessous dame g5 ça
met un peu de pression sur g2 ya pas mal
de deux pièces noires qui peuvent
attaquer ce pion déclaré lee qui peuvent
jaillir avec des fous bessette
ça a été chassé tout de suite l on
s'attend à cavaler b d2 et le fouet
fuite peut toujours pas vraiment sortir
à cause de fou prend g7 en tête à
l'euphrate ur g8
je pense qu'elle va partir pour x l x 7
laisser le pion g7 est attaquée elle
fait grand remous la la ça paraît
bizarre il ya tour c1 dames 2 oulala
elle est en train de déjouer la dame de
jouer direct bien joué de la part de
koné roux termine le développement
quasiment la tour c'est un tour assez un
autour fcim l'une des deux mois je
mettrais plutôt là à store de garder la
sève pour la colonne des si jamais et
après ça peut partir en cavale id&t
catways suivant bon je sais pas
exactement mais on sent que les noirs
ils ont ils ont une position un petit
peu bizarre l'allèle allèles dam tour à
ses seins elle se place en face du roi
du roi noir
le machin qui bouge et maintenant tour
ces deux tours c'est un et ça va faire
mal aux cavale lacaune héros qui
pourrait jouer un peu plus vite
après saison s'il a de prendre son temps
mais là ça et que ça semble pas être les
coups les plus durs du monde à jouer
allez on va voir si elle les joues plus
que 50 secondes c'est peut-être dommage
de laisser lucho rêve d un sachet un peu
étonné puisque torcé deux tours c'est un
tu mets quand même tellement de pression
sur deux pièces dans le cavalier c'est
si ses protégés mais tu attaques des
pièces quand même fragile
je trouve un petit peu étrange ce choix
mais elle doit vouloir renforcer le fou
éviter des dames des 5 ou quoi qui
devait la gêne et même s'ils avouent eux
quatre elle doit vouloir éviter quelque
chose mais c'est très difficile à jouer
pour alexandre à mon avis le beauf ou
des six est intéressant ici histoire de
te quand même mettre une pression mais
elle doit être gêné par cavalier e 4
c'est chiant
bref c'est dur à jouer vraiment avec les
noirs alexandra qui qui se retrouve de
nouveau mal autant elle peut être en
train de choke totalement alexandra et
ségou nina qui doit se frotter les mains
donc m6 il ya peut-être un retour ces
deux maintenant je sais pas tout ça me
paraît tellement logique depuis tout à
l'heure
fort que koné ou réussissent à ya
peut-être ça aussi qui est fort tout
repenser 6 france et six cavaliers ou 5
1 mais adam 8 maintenant bien joué parce
que sinon dame prend à eux deux qui
avaient prend ses six vous prend au jeu
et ses protégés c'était peut-être ça
l'idée de m pied maintenant elle fait b
4 allée 36 secondes chaque 34 secondes
chacune pardon on va voir si l'une des
deux femmes réussi à placer une action
où la leffe ou prend un f6 bêtement ouh
là là où lalalalalala fou prend f6 ça
fait très mal c'est la gaffe là pour
pour alexandra est un peu un peu de
manière surprenante impies qui a fait
tourner le match au moment où on s'y
attendait le moins bon là il ya juste la
position gagnante qui va falloir
terminer peut-être fou e4 ici est sympa
de toute façon la fourchette les tours
vont pas s'envoler cavaliers avaient
faim tu as intérêt à te laisser attaquer
d'aller à les prendre dans un deuxième
temps iphone 4 l'om c'était peut-être ça
voilà elle voulait pas moi j'ai mon idée
c'est de faire [ __ ] ans et 6 mai
d'accord elle veut jouer comme ça par
contre elle se mettrait mal autant c'est
dommage on est fou et 4 jouer maintenant
carvelli g3 et c'est dommage alors perdu
beaucoup de temps là dans la petite
phase de stabilisation
elle aurait pu jouer un peu plus vite et
pas se faire aussi peur ce que l'avait
peut-être des cavaliers f3 qui rôdait
c'était pas sûr que ça marche un mot
elle a pris ses 4 elle fait n'importe
quoi il ya vous prend h2 maintenant et
on prend des 1
ouais c'est terrible après un petit lac
i qui a vraiment fait n'importe quoi et
c'est dommage causé nuke qui va tourner
à +1 mais m6 qui a vraiment fait un
cadeau on voit alexandra qui se tient le
visage et qui tourne à plus 1 contre le
cours du jeu du coup mais qui va qui va
pouvoir entamer le 1 + 1 avec une énorme
confiance en la joueuse russe qui mène
d'un point face à m puis allez on va
prendre une dernière respiration dans
cette finale et donc je vous rappelle
l'enjeu si kosteniuk joue et gagne cette
finale
c'est ainsi qu'au sud gagne cette finale
elle jouera demain la grande finale
contre contre ou chez nina si elle perd
ses goûts nina qui jouera la finale
donc voilà l'enjeu je vous repasse la
partie précédente en entier et nous on
se retrouve dans cinq petites minutes
pour le dénouement de la faim premier
dénouement de la compétition avant le
dénouement final donc demain à partir de
15h à tout de suite tout le monde
m
moi
les amis on va repartir pour pour le
bullet déjouer ce qu'ils viennent de
revenir
c'est en train de devant un peu ce que
ce que ça disait pendant la pause et
donc on va se retrouver un pour ces
bulles est qu'ils vont qui vont envoyer
du lourd il n'y a qu'un point d'écart
entre entre les deux joueuses
et ça y est c'est parti 4pour kosteniuk
que cinq élèves trois cas et si je vous
rappelle l'enjeu de cette série de
bulles est l'enjeu c'est une
qualification en finale du speech s pour
kosteniuk et une victoire dans ce
quatrième phase étape du grand prix pour
pour un pic au nez roule à petrov qui
est envoyé par la joueuse noir et
maintenant la joueuse blanche donc
alexandra kosteniuk qui met le pion en
décathlon qui contrôle le centre fou g4
qui arrive est peut-être un cavalier un
des cinq cavaliers 17 qui va qui va
partir alors le cavalier blanc qui
arrive en c4 ont retardé le coups des
cinq peut-être pour contrôler la case e
5 avec le pion alors le fou qui reniant
h5 avec l'idée de jouer plutôt avec fuji
si si si et et conserver un contrôle
deux des cinq mais peut-être que
maintenant les pneus avons décidé de
jouer l'option en d5 pour égaliser le
centre nom elle décide de garder son
pion en d6 alors à la de la flexibilité
avec les noirs elle fait c'est si c'est
le contrôle bien le centre à tout moment
elle pourra jouer pour dessein calmer la
dame en c7 et elle termine quasiment le
développement les blancs qui peuvent
partir à tout moment pour du cavalier f5
ça peut ça peut partir mais voilà
cavalier seul qui part avec l'idée
éventuellement de d'envoyer le foin f4
non le pion des cinq qui empêche tout ça
et les noirs qui ont bien réussi à
contrôler cette case e5 ça ressemble les
amis à une variante des changes de la
française les noirs qui ont conservé le
contrôle 2,5 et qui réussissent à
frapper sur la case e 4 en premier donc
les noirs une position ici tout à fait
convenable cavaliers hk dessous des 6
développement pour les noirs qui
reviennent avec un fou qui peut arriver
en f4 à tout moment ici on hésite un
peut-être ffe pour jouer tout réfuté la
colonne f ou alger pour jouer f5 et le
contrôle du centre cng qui part avec
tour f 8 tours 8 à venir la position est
très compliqué mais la joueuse indienne
a de nouveau un gros retard à la pendule
et ça c'est évidemment largement
al'avantage le kosteniuk qui a
maintenant 20 secondes d'avancé et qui
va pouvoir peut-être faire parler sa
pointe de vitesse pour mettre en danger
son adversaire mais les noirs qui
peuvent enchaîner peut-être du c5 du
cavalier ou 5 qui arrive dans ya le fou
qui arrive en f4 attention ainsi le
cavalier part de la case des deux y aura
éventuellement la case f3 pour les noirs
et peut-être un plan comme tours sète
tours fc peut arriver un jour ou l'autre
côté new qui commence à se mobiliser
face à ce pion eu 4 qui échangent en f4
et qui joue dame g3 très bien joué pour
échanger les dames et venir s'emparer
maintenant du pion aux 4 qui s'offrent à
elle causé new qui a fait la différence
dans cette partie qui maintenant à un
pion un net davance l'avantagent autant
une petite dame trois peut-être pour
tout couvrir suivi de tours 8 qui semble
faire très mal aux la huitième ranger
est en lambeaux et la hausse et 5 qui
coupe la connexion et kosteniuk qui va
gagner la première partie d'un messi ce
roi je suis tu es tout reprend f8 maths
ça y est kosteniuk qui prend deux points
d'avance il reste deux ou trois parties
la joue et ça a joué quand même assez
vite la première il peut encore y avoir
trois parties mais c'est clairement déjà
une première balle de match pour la
joueuse russe qui a maintenant deux
points d'avancé maximum comme je vous
disais trois parties à jouer donc ça
repart pour koné ou dans ce genre de
système cole gambie dame refusait qui
s'était plutôt bien passé mais là il est
peut-être un fou des cinq échecs qui
faisait très mal côté koné roux qui a
été ratée sur calais 17 et puis on prend
1,6 ça avait l'air de quasiment être
games pour les blancs mais koné rookie
raté conejo qui commence à rater ses
chances ici kosteniuk qui et qui fait
qui fait une sacrée différence sur
cahier des deux peut-être des cavaliers
4 qui peuvent être gênants et 6ème
piccone ou perd cette partie s'en sera
fini des espoirs de l'indienne et de
boue nina par ricochet ici sûrement que
c'est nous qui va reprendre du cavalier
en c3 qui attaquent ce cavalier c3 qui
va jouer cavalier 17 qui va mobiliser
une tour ans et 8 qui va mettre la
pression grave j'ai envie de dire sur
sur ce pion sur ce cavalier pardon puis
après sur ce pion g2 qui peut qui peut
être en ligne de mire cavale yeux de qui
revient
c'était probablement le seul coup et
maintenant petit rock qui part avec de
gros problèmes pour les blancs le fou
sur la bonne diagonale des cavaliers
français 3 okairos 3
j'ai cinq os est terrible c'est terrible
d'alger 5 double attaque aux dames g5
qui peut aussi une balle en c'est une
sacrée balle de qualification là pour
pour kosteniuk aux dames g5y qui semble
faire mal menace maths on ne le fait pas
elle ne fait pas sa menace et mater dame
prend b5 hausse était sacrément formé
kosteniuk qui garde un avantage certain
dans cette position même si la position
est assez équilibré maintenant il ya il
ya un écart autant quand même qui est
important une vingtaine de secondes et
la joueuse russe qui va qui va pouvoir
faire parler la technique je pense que
si la partie dure un match nul devrait
lui suffire pour remporter la
compétition
enfin remporter le quatrième la
quatrième étape et avoir une balle de
compétition pas une finale de
compétition donc on va voir comment
comment ça se passe mal on connaît
rookie a réussi à gagner un pion avec
les blancs 13 secondes contre contre
contre 37 ça va être tendu qu'au nehru
qui est quand même favorite avec cet
avantage à la pendule mais là
obligations obligations obligation de
gagner sinon ça en sera fini à mon avis
de ses chances et là haut il ya
peut-être des fous 1 qui rôde aussi sa
peau faut avouer encore mais fou un
échec ça fait quand même mal an la
finale là avec le pion passé éloigné est
bonne en cadets change maintenant que
c'est nous qui décide d'aller prendre le
pion g2 mais qui laisse le contre je
c'est peut-être dommage de pas être
parti pour la finale de pièces mineurs
avec fou contre cavaliers et puis on pas
s'éloigner mais elle a pris la décision
de garder les pièces sur l'échiquier
attention à peut-être 4 puis on prend
pour faire un parapluie à les attaquer
non là il ya peut-être b saint calais b
5 pour que ses gnocchis et/ou reprend
2,3 en bessin que ça semble fort à la
fesfut f2 être proches s'attaquent aux
pions et 3 puis on vous prend 1,3 wife
six fois ça peut être très chaud en f3
f4 c'est fini c'est fini les amis à tout
prix quatre emplois menacés et menace le
cavalier c'est terminé c'est terminé co
senio qui ira en finale du speech est
féminin ça y est c'est officiel conejo
qui craque sur une gaffe une nouvelle
fois trois points d'écart et là il y
aura jamais trois parties dans ce match
c'en est terminé les amis de ceux de
cette quatrième étape des speechless et
une grande félicitations à alex ans
accosté nuke qui remporte qui remporte
ce match et qui aura été solide un tout
du long
elle est forte dans toutes les cadences
elle réussit à faire tourner les parties
qu'il faut tourner ce qu'il faut faire
tourner et valeureuse elle réussit donc
à se qualifier a terminé première de ces
grands prix finalement la joueuse qui
tient le plus l'habitude des joutes sur
internet et des parties sur thiès comme
sera en finale les amis des speechs est
féminin face à uche et nina hanau chez
nina la joue et ukrainienne qui a fait
mal à tout le monde avec son système de
londres dans cette compétition et qui va
avoir un match exceptionnel demain à
partir de 15h contre alexandra kosteniuk
qui s'impose donc dans ce quatrième
manche des speechs s féminin les amis et
koné rookie pourra s'en vouloir un qui
pourra s'en vouloir de passe est un peu
plus entraînés en sueur sur les joutes
internet mais on sent qu'elle a un
potentiel énorme et c'est vraiment une
une grande joueuse à on a on peut
regretter que willy fanco nehru et joua
jun n'est pas n'est pas un peu mieux
défendu leur chance elle semblait dans
le fond de jeu un peu plus forte mais
moins forte sur internet peut être aussi
moins forte en blitz
c'était des oppositions de style
intéressante et c'est quand même les
mouches et li na qui a quand même fait
fait la surprise de la compétition en
allant en finale je m'y attendais pas
mais au goût nina aussi gros joueuses
sur internet qui a plus l'habitude et
qui joue vite en rapide
que scénique mairie tout évidemment
comme ditto crasse sur l'ensemble de la
compétition largement sur sur sur ce
match c'était équilibré
chacune des joueuses avaient avait son
registre et c'est celui de kosteniuk qui
s'est trouvée le plus fort donc ce soir
nous on aura à partir de 20 heures la
sélection pour pour le soc battle contre
les jazz bras donc on se retrouvera sur
sur ce live
la laine noire qui ont deux pièces de
plus mais bon il y aura je sais pas
combien il reste de temps exactement
j'ai plus le téléphone dans l'est dans
les mains mais mais très clairement il
va pas rester assez de temps pour avoir
encore deux parties les parties la
partie 2 qui a duré la partie trois là
qui dure qui dure aussi kosteniuk qui
s'est forcément qu'elle doit jouer
jusqu'au bout de la nuit jusqu'au bout
du temps donc il ya déjà une quarantaine
de coups joués et et la partie qui va
durer à mon avis a minima 50 55 coûts et
si elle est si elle est maligne à
l'abandonnera pas elle prendra son temps
et elle laissera elle se laissera tomber
au pire j'ai passé la dernière partie ou
l'avant-dernière quoi mais ça peut pas
ça peut pas être différent alaya joli
ton coin f3 et sur dame pranger six
tours l2 tours est fait un tour f2 donc
là normalement s est pas très bien jouer
de se laisser perdre je vais aller
vérifier le temps qui reste
mais je vois pas dans quel cas de figure
il reste assez pour jouer encore cette
partie et qui reste assez de temps à la
fin ça me semble complètement impossible
il reste 37 secondes de jeu donc à moins
d'un cas de figures incroyables ou à
kosteniuk abandonne par mégarde c'est
terminé c'est complètement terminée il
ya aucune chance de revenir là il doit
rester une quinzaine de secondes comme
julia moins d'un mystique sur l'abandon
ya aucun aucun moyen de perdre ce match
consigne qui gagnera avec un petit écart
1 koné roula qui a encore une bonne
partie mais le match et ai gagné donc le
prochain la turbie triment pour la seule
bataille commence à 20h30 l'as battle
donc à 20h on commencera la sélection
pour le match et demain 15h lundi 15
heures la grande finale de ce pitch est
féminin entre ou chez nina et kosteniuk
bas il continua à continuer à jouer mais
c'est officiellement gagné pour
alexandra kosteniuk mais ça joue sajou
quand même ce concept battles et un
match entre seube
bon ben bravo bravo bravo à kosteniuk
qui aura qui aura quand même fait son
match et elle est plus complète
elle n'a pas peut-être moins de points
faibles qu il ya quand même jouer pour
gagner même si moi je répèterai juste
les coûts en voyant que le match est
fini mais les joueuses qui jouent
toujours jusqu'au bout quoi qu'il en
soit même quand il n'ya plus d'enjeu
elle continua à se donner à fond et
c'est tout à l'heure tout à leur honneur
tout cas bravo
pour cette compétition qui prendra fin
demain
après si on prend les qualifications à
peu près un mois et demi de compétition
on va voir c'est dommage pour elle
qu'elle puisse pas ramené un fou vers f6
mais là le plan paraît un peu long
on va voir comment ça continue mais
évidemment la partie n'a plus grand
intérêt mais bravo à 1 et kosteniuk un
vraiment bien joué gros match de la part
de la joueuse russe
ah c'est pas mal joué seul à s'inquiéter
surtout prendre faire fois à troyes et
b4 malin et sur pied on prend elle veut
faire food et 4 à 1 pi qui jouent
vraiment pas mal on prend un fou des 4
es fou 1,8 peut-être maintenant est sûr
c'est qu'il veut jouer avec fouille 8
pour attaques des deux côtés mais
maintenant peut-être fou j'ai six fours
bessette a il faut prouver si ça c'est
dommage aurait été fou prend v6 c'est
con pas assez de temps qui m'arrive
leroy c3 et et pousser à la vente mais
c'est pas évident à gagner ça
il faut prendre 4 elle a réussi à à
dribbler koné roues sans adversaire a
obligé de remettre le fou c'est toujours
pas évident à gagner je pense qu'elle va
pouvoir à faudrait peut-être le foie en
g2a emea fouet fait maintenant elle rate
fouet fin il faut enfin une nouvelle
fois il faut en effet un ses formes
parce que roy ses sept blocs le pion à
faire du c6 roi prend fou prend aussi
souffrent h3 elle menace h5 food et st
croix bouche fouet f3 mais ça à faire un
blocus
elle va pas pouvoir avancer parti qui
durent donc il manqué largement de temps
pour pour aller plus loin dans ces mêmes
kosteniuk y est gagnante finalement koné
roux qui a tout donné pour gagner la
partie que c'est mieux qu'ils ramassent
les pions et qui file à dam à l'arrêt
encore wef 4 x 3 rois g5 g2 ça va tout
échange et ça va faire un nul et voilà
alexandra qui encore stressé mais elle
devrait savoir pourtant qui a que trois
parties en bullet et c'est terminé
victoire d'alexandre a causé nuke donc
et la grande finale demain à 15 heures
je vous le rappelle merci à tous d'avoir
suivi cette quatrième étape des grands
prix et
et je vous dis donc à demain pour pour
la grande finale qui se jouera sur sur
trois heures 30 ce sera un match
beaucoup plus longs pour la grande
finale
merci à tous et à tous d'avoir suivi ce
match jusqu'à maintenant et à à demain
quoi ce soir pour le seul bateau là
demain pour pour la finale ciao ciao